um okay this is for the ear of the lord watchers put the ink in the bag and no one gets hurt
our little secret lord watchers oh my screen just went black oh we're in good
oh my gosh it's president the one who got sucked off a pile
let's see um i i don't know your life my son my son oh i've not got hold on i got a live chat on
versus top chat i saw that always tries to catch me out i'm like
um
bear oh my eyeballs hi top chat here yes sorry okay good morning good evening get out dinning
hi oh my screen's black wait hold on my screen goes black when i open up black ops okay it's fine
it's fine i was like it's the president that got sucked off under the desk
no not that one no sure the one wait no wait it wasn't him he was the one that got headshot in the
car who was the one that got that diddle the onesky oh bill clinton i that shows you
i that that's right that's right a lot of people say like oh she was a home wrecker whatever i'm like
the president of the united states and the secretary you know touch tips who's the one
taking advantage of the other yeah i don't know maybe hold on a minute maybe we're a bit harsh on
this Lewinsky chick let's say i roll the fridge let's roll the fridge look at you know american
history like i know the important parts of american history and i assure you uh i did not have sexual
relations with that woman is peak american history it's also american a psychology in terms of lying
and when you lie you take away the emphasis on the person so when he said the sentence
that woman instead of either naming her and addressing her by saying i did not have a like her
and that's actually peak psychology when you don't directly address
hey like if you go like strongy did this strongy did that to me when i didn't consent
that's much likely you're telling the truth but yeah is this a blind pray for it no i'm good with
the sauce in this game she says that she's playing with a controller on recruit mode um resume game
i don't have a file on this account so there's no resume game oh there's no resume game i know
my controller's not registering oh no don't do this to me oh right okay we're gonna show you
how to get the zork achievement on mouse and keyboard oh no whoa what no i don't have this
i really hope this is the start of the freaking campaign we've thrown myself in it but i actually
didn't oh yeah my mouse uh my game and controllers and thing in my tentacles are up dude shit yeah
i like i ain't got my glasses on all i'm saying is my aim's a little bit rough right now
that's the last level get me out
okay it why on earth did you i don't it's not all right new game enter yes
uh veteran mode yep the hardest it's first thing in the morning it's too bright for this
oh where's resnov oh congrats if your name's mason hi mason hi alex hi woods hi
me this is this is me getting interrogated for what that secret is that i can't spill yet
that's actually a reflin in that room right up there
what's the secret scrawny what can you tell us fuck you kiss my ass
okay let me turn the volume up i'll turn it up after this cutscene
to know anything about any special
the bay of pigs
the numbers are um what do you mean i owe so many ASMR videos
uh
you know sorry i'm pulling it and loose eyelash that's in my eye
uh oh if you just bowman correct congrats i don't know why you call yourself bowman but
oh my god i just pulled like three eyelashes though until i got the one that was
the six digit code ah the four numbers on the back of your credit card
what are the 10 steps of freedom step one secure the keys right i need to be able to pause this
okay where is this is the audio quiet because it's quiet what voice is that no sound
no i have to do it manually hold on hold on let me do it manually
sorry my screen's black i don't know what happens when my screen goes black i assume
the stream just stays normal i'm gonna put it up by like um seven decibels seven decibels yeah
step two ascension of darkness
stream contains is normal our graphics on high this is a very old game actually you know what
well some i'm cheekily on my desktop how long did production for black ops one take
college a black ops within 24 hours on sale the game had sold more than 5.6 million copies
and that was not by me because i never got the game until later
because my dad didn't want me to play college a because of the airport scene and modern warfare
too remember um 14 years old i bet you're starting to start singing scottish war songs
losing guns ablazing secure the winged beast oh that's a good one oh
okay i got my cup of tea wait can i quickly ramble to you about all the things that i did okay so the
video game lanes are done and they're about to be sent off okay and then amy and ac and mersey
definitely 100 percent have all their emotes sent off in a batch and then mersey had something
sin and he had something and i did also work last night um today patreon's gonna get an update
of a saucepan of a naughty saucepan of an audio patreon's gonna get an update um and uh it may
also have a uh update of 5000 special which is ear brushing ASMR no talking i didn't accidentally
oh strony i had a new rp idea rifling gets a new job and finds you but plays innocent
you tease them with like microsoft edging then train them
um well i'm gonna make his microsoft super hard in a minute thank you sir givona
and you're super cherry don't mind if i do um uh what was i saying this
i do want to do a roleplay where you're in the office and listening like i said what i said i
don't care look call me controversial call me sorry sorry just checking out my dms hold on real
quick
hey hold on why am i getting pinged in ginger
what
sorry sorry hi hi back to already being distracted by work okay no work everyone's
getting ignored i'm playing black ops with the refluence we're all jerking each other sorry
um did my chat break no did mine
we're being held at gunpoint a wee bit only cousin love this did you get rest at least
so i have my soup ingredients i have i got red is it red split pea lentils
or they look like carrot a little bits of carrot but they're not um so i got that i got i don't know
why i forgot about onion the staple of a freaking soup and then i went to go buy chicken bouillon
and couldn't find it and then i ended up buying the wrong thing and and i know what the right one
looks like now and i'm so mad at myself because i second guessed it because in australia we're closer
to um like uh china there was a chinese bouillon like chicken bouillon but it was in chinese but
it looked like the right thing and i was like maybe maybe but then i decided not to go with it
and i went home and i looked at uh i watched like um cooking videos and someone pulled out the very
freaking chicken bouillon and i'm like no a second guess so the long story short don't second guess
yourself or you're gonna mess it up have you tried stockpots i would i think bouillon is actually
better than stockpots i got like a different thing i'm so sorry if no one cares about a soup let me
just talk about my soup okay i'm passionate about it i got mushrooms i got carrot onion potatoes
garlic uh and then the base is going to be the chicken because i got willy's chicken but
the magpies never came out to see me i normally feed the magpie some chicken when i get it but
gimley and vego had some chicken uh um so i need to pick the chicken off of the actual bones and
then i need to boil the bones in the uh like two liters of water for like two hours and that'll
make the base and it may not need too much flavor after that because like the flavoring comes from
like out of the like it oozes out the bones and stuff i don't know if it's called collagen
but um i just need to cut up all the vegetables and i was going to roast them in the oven boy
your mama like that kind of roast um and put like all the season and stuff then whack it in
then whack some chicken back into the liquid and then if it goes nicely i'm gonna freeze it all
and then it means i have healthy soup for the next few days and if that goes super well put
um then i can it's my no my makes it looks like my makes the lid a little bit like it's not instant
um that sounds more like a stew to me um probably um i want more me soup
well i'm gonna make an ace more roleplay of my fish broth i don't know what we're doing for next
weeks uh well it's next months but there's really only a week left to this month and then i would
have streamed for three months consecutively do da do da i am poggers i didn't know what to i didn't
know what to like accolade myself with there i was like i just feel like an achievement but i didn't
know what to say about it i was i was going to start singing the Homer Simpson i am so smart
marty um yes you are i can imagine story where nothing but an apron kicking in the kitchen
for us and i'm coming for it could you imagine a more cheerful come home but i'm like a dog waiting
for the master come home we're like we're feeling how is your day i made food food food hungry hungry
yes food you said it not and sadly we part of the the thought gang it is i the fake link no you're
not fake link that's not the voice gang work um you are cool and the best and i like you and i
watch you more or less every day because you're funny and i think you're nice and cool and i'm
the best oh thank you reef when i'm such a nice little marshmallow good morning to you do you
um
whoa
hold on a minute can i read this one
um
wouldn't i be the problem hold on wait i'm going to read this one out this is
rather risky rather risky okay but i'm going to read this one out
hi strongy hi reading i've been a popcorn addict for a few years along with all the
mental health issues that come with it but about two months ago i took heart and started
to get my life together the reason i'm writing this is because your overwhelming positivity
sparked this flame of change in me the way you take these issues serious and how you foster
a healthy relationship to adult content in your community has really helped me understand a few
things about myself also i'd rather just do the deed along your page for subscription than see
myself listen again am i the problem for you or not am i bad for you or not yesterday i invited
all my friends to talk with me through the dark times for dinner and while i was preparing
while i was preparing my favorite song from long ago started playing and i cracked the
feeling of giving it all you're all for other people and putting the effort in and the positive
change and currently experience made me cry tears of joy as i cried for the first time in five years
oh that's nice not and not like tears of joy it's a tears of joy thank you for giving me motivation
oh thank you i thought i was gonna be the problem but that's why i was a bit concerned when i
read the start i was like aren't i a problem for you but if you're actually ignorant you know
you're the solution mommy is what it sounded like maybe maybe i gave like a new perception
because it's like it's like oh we doing it together yeah like uh i guess yeah yeah maybe
because we did it together it makes it more thingy reeflings love whoever you are even if i'm
well i'm broken reefling wifey roleplay but she tackles us with sniffing and licking and
summer day when oh i wish i could do that for youtube because it's not exactly like uh
oh patreon audio strone is medicine
i think he holds it all in until your next patreon upload i mean i guess if you're like a daily
or maybe multiple times a day and like sometimes you can identify if you're kind of
in yourself and it's like oh this isn't going that good um but i'm glad i'm glad that's so good
i'm sorry that um i'm hoping you had a lovely dinner with your pals i hope you made them tavern
food i just realized tavern master is called taven master uh on the stream and i never fixed it
like a lazy bone um you better have your cake decorated for me when i come home to you i'm
talking about frosting everywhere and a candle stick out your star happy birthday question mark
happy birthday okay let me finish my tea
mm okay and now let me crank into this water
mm finally able to catch a stream hi we're playing black ops i'm just doing my ritual
yapping before the actual gameplay starts i'm hydrating
scottish partner beats you a smart as funny as that is unfortunately the domestic violence
rates on both parties in scotland are a rarer hi um i'm not sure i would get away with that one okay
okay can it doesn't it like okay i acknowledges mouse and keyboard takeovers
i'm gonna try look it's me in the background at the tavern hi there traveler
for a mere five gold coin you can get what you want that turns this is not a microphone to load
track them enough to get you inside well thank you but tell me if the audio is too loud because
i can change it in game now just be there excellent why am i so tan i'm in Cuba even though i can't
tan i don't have the tan jean oh bad me no
being so mean to her damn she ran quick she let you see him bolt i'm out
bleep oh shit oh no i'm playing mouse and keyboard what was that that was embarrassing i'm playing
mouse and keyboard get that controller out here what was that i'm so embarrassed i'm actually so
embarrassed sorry we're playing mouse and keyboard let me let me set up the mic okay that was awful
that was genuinely embarrassing who am i shooting oh my god i can't see i need like the game color
right that car's gonna blow up don't trust it there you go
no don't give me prompts for the fucking give me prompts for mouse and keyboard don't do this to
me now give me prompts for mouse and keyboard i'm literally no not gamepad no look move combat
what right and then tell me what's up with combat use five for a grenade launcher what logic is that
how do i run okay sprint crouch okay crouch is normal that's all i want to see baby and we're
gonna go down oh no we're not sorry sorry hold on i just woke up be nice to me that was carlos
congrats everybody names carlos you've never did one but you did two um one and two are the same
bloodline um so we're playing as uh what's going on we're playing as my son right and we have a
son yeah called alex that's in black ops team so i'm not paying attention to me
what am i supposed to do i mean i'm supposed to follow all right follow them into the alley
i'm stuck on the mp2 oh you ready to watch me drive this is gonna be terrible
all right i'm in
use right mouse to reverse not wrong one oh that one close enough i tried left and right
you know sometimes it's a bit more difficult than you uh you first imagine oh my god i'm driving
can't watch stream tonight because of work so i ll just ask is the in open later tonight
oh i'm flooring i'm flooring thank you mumaloo i'm sorry that you can't watch uh the in will
develop shortly yeah we will do the upstairs i think we'll go back on it
don't get car sick i'm sorry oh god this game is very it's a reactive model kind of stream
there's a compound oh wait if i do reactive models my hand's gonna be reactive any minute
there's a signal now hook up this is it so that's weird that's for men and it's just me hold f to zip
sign oh to zip line to zip sign we should look in the game for minner and it'd be bad what's that
you don't want to wait every 15 seconds for five seconds to load over and over again
so we're playing with that m16 it's a three burst fire weapon all the weapons i know in
real life are from this game the intel's here wait what i thought the intel was in this room
i'm comming
i'm sneaking up on you
oh i forgot about the the f in fell this is like a
it's a single fire this one
i hate burst fire i hate it so
here we go
but yes we're sneaking we're super sneaky i'm
oh my god look at the flowers it's so pretty hello mr flower
i know we're in a combat zone but come on you sometimes you gotta stop and smell the nature
i remember playing black ops one then when you a baby you never know maybe i wrecked you in public
matches huh maybe maybe i dominated you maybe i pup stomped you have you shouldn't
all right what we're doing woods let me know
no
there's a game not registering i'm costing off them woods what's the plan
oh right okay combat engaged i thought we were still sneaking around i was like uh wood uh what
we're doing oh the scorpion that's a rubbish one are you the families you're not the families go
away i don't want you go away
uh the first black op experience was on the way
i don't know if that technically makes you an elite gamer for putting up with that oh no the intel's
in this room
but yeah this game is very highly rated it's very good um they did remaster it if i'm not
mistaken where is the intel i swear it's in this room i'm losing it
i swear the intel the intel is on a crate on this level and it's like in a room that goes like this
i'm going for you i swear i swear it's in here
am i what i must have missed it there's no way
right fine i'll pretend that i don't know where the intels are it's on the barrel
it's yellow and tiny
i'm gone is this a fresh save i don't know maybe it's not maybe it remembers the last thing i've
played it a very long time ago now um maybe it remembers and i have picked it up
well velar cod zombies would go hard
was she be she be um is getting an interest in sure games and i'm like
and azura said she also played um what was it was it called or something something that surprised
me i wouldn't pick her out for the game because uh obviously when i first met her all i knew it was
legal age and so i'm getting absolutely twat in this whole week um right what's melee um
hold on hold on let me put melee on my uh me me me me mostly for
er um aim both enemies jeez yeah you're going to build them i can hardly see like the color
difference is really hard to see past. Oh, I'm on fire. What was that? B-26? We only
stand B-52s out here. No one's dropping a Famous. I'm starting to think this is personal,
buddy. Sorry, I'm trying to get kills through the furniture. There's another one in here.
Merda putana. I've been looking and loving and thinking and drinking. Is there only two?
Is there anyone else? Gears this. Why no, Gears this. This is the RPK with an ACOG.
Now, did I like ACOG personally? I'm not much of an ACOG-er. Oh, no, not the pistol.
Okay, so we kill him, right? And then she... I forgot about the holy music that randomly plays.
And then she goes for you as well. She's got quite a little darts, eh? So I've got an ACOG.
She still protects him. She still protects him.
All right, back to the campaign. Me who's taking the campaign is so super serious right now.
I'm so serious. An MLG bro. Jeez, the recoil on this was harsh. I don't put burn on B.
I just want a Famous. Is that too much to ask? Famous Jewel Wheel. You walked past the enemy!
Oh, that's Bowman. Sorry, sorry, Bowman. Look, can you wear a different color from the enemy?
I'm needing support. Why are we all the same color as the enemies? Can't we not wear something
that clearly... Bro, I can't even see. Am I going crazy? Am I not hitting the targets?
No, I'm going down the stairs. No, leave me alone.
This is too many enemies for a level. This is the intro. Come at work, grand Geneva suggestion.
I think the Famous wasn't invented in this year. Wait, this is historically accurate too. No,
I know they did a lot of Gucci stuff. Who just fired an RPG at me? Own up to...
Own up to who just literally fired an RPG at me. That's a bit dramatic, even by my standards.
Who did it? Own up to it. That's not... Ow! How are you spawning behind us? We've done a new checkpoint.
Right, who's therapy? Is it you? No. Who did it? Own up to it. I'm looking for you.
I can't see over the fire. I can see these guys shooting though. Hold on. Hold on.
Uh-huh. Mm-hmm. Yep. Mm-hmm. Take that. And this. And this. I think there's someone there.
The muzzle flashes are literally given all other positions away.
Calphish down. I don't know who's throwing the RPGs though.
I'm getting like... I actually have a freaking cover fire. Which one of you was it? Seriously,
that RPG thing was insane. Wait, did they keep respawning in the same place? I just said support.
It's okay, you're doing a great job. I'll support you.
There's too many of them.
But what am I... Oh, are we moving up? I thought...
Carlos, what's happening?
Carlos!
Oh, Granada!
Luges!
Okay.
Ow!
They're high.
What do you mean I can't just sponge billets through the entire campaign mode?
Ooh!
Look at those.
Those are B-52s.
Those are carpet bombers.
They go do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do.
And wipe out massive areas.
They are!
What am I supposed to do?
I'm like on Mino, which is this game, like, a lot harder than I remember.
I don't remember being like this at all.
Someone spawned behind me?
Maybe you're just Mino.
All right.
Just let me be patient, my games.
I'm having a good time, having a good time, having a good time, committing war, crimes
across the country, and I won't be, what's the word, when you get done for it in court,
and I won't be...
The rebels are getting the asses kicked.
I can't.
What's...
What's it called?
I won't be prosecuted.
No, I won't, because I serve my country.
For the billion-dollar contracts, because they're coming through the stocks, yeah.
A hundred degrees, that's against the law, but don't stop me now, because I have a flame
woofer.
Don't stop me, because I'm having a flame woofer time.
Tomahawk is the best weapon.
Really?
I never used Tomahawks in this game, the Baylor.
Thank you.
Mummy's up.
Ah!
No, it's only funny when I do the weapon destruction and stuff.
Can't wait any longer, will.
So we're just going to spray and pray down everything.
Like I kid you not everything.
It doesn't matter who or what it is, it's getting done.
Bop, bop, bop, bop, bop, bop, bop, bop, bop, bop, bop, bop, bop.
Like, laddo, go to hell.
They're going to call me the new Bluetooth, the way I'll be connecting these bullets to
your forehead.
We didn't know Bluetooth was actually a Viking that connected large regions together that
were once thought like, oh, XD, impossible, because they hate each other, but then the
Viking named Bluetooth.
What's the problem?
Am I about to get, okay, they'll chew you up at them.
I'm spraying, but nothing's happening.
Okay, there we go.
Okay, time to get captured.
Can I not hit the, ah!
I'm just an innocent little mason, I didn't hurt anybody, I may have committed one or
two war crimes, but that wasn't my fault.
I had to do it.
I didn't kill you.
No, you killed a double.
His name wasn't Bluetooth, no.
Vikings are normally named after either their wisdom or physical attributes, so he most
likely had a rotten tooth, and that's why he was called Bluetooth.
Well, the suffering beyond his darkest fears.
Mommy now gets to go to the ink dungeon.
I hate planes, but you win, baby.
I don't know how much Vikings are named like Argonians in Skyrim, the main break about
to commence.
I'm on my high way, sir.
To Incutor?
That's so good.
Crazy, there are like 117 attempts on Castro and all we wanted to do was be a dictator
and breathe.
The perfect cow.
Wait, is that real?
Like an actual cow?
Or he meant like Breda as an insult towards...
Doesn't the pod scream if safe you have the intel or not?
It definitely was in that second place, so because it was registered that I picked it
up, it might remember the last time I played on this computer.
Oh my god.
I was watching as there was a birthday stream.
This is completely off topic and not related.
Right, hold on.
Let's do the cutscenes first and then I'll see the other thing.
Rest off.
There's a man on me, I don't know if he's a reflinger.
Is there a speedy...
Is it related to the fuckup?
Yeah.
Oh no, we're getting in trouble.
I'm sorry.
Obliet.
No.
Leave him alone.
Monk.
Hi, rest off.
Hi.
That's me.
Secure the keys.
Warcoota.
War is step two.
Ascent from darkness.
Three.
Right.
Fire.
I rang fire.
I missed that one, sorry.
I got attacked there.
Five.
Four.
Six.
Five.
No.
Oh, I'm sorry, we're supposed to...
Look at him.
Okay.
Friend.
Pri distributation care.
caring care care care care care care care care care care care care care care care care care
care care care care care care care care care care care care care care care care care care care care care
care care care care care care care care care care care care care care care care care care care care
Oh, we're in a cutscene?
No, we're not the horde and warcraft. We're the goodies. We're the alliance, for the alliance.
Abandoned.
Hydration check.
Send from Fart?
Is it really bad I farted on Gimli?
Right. I've said this the other day,
but Gimli likes to bite my butt to wake me up when she wants attention and I'm like, no, I'm
sleep- wait, why can't I pick this up? I'm like, no, I'm sleeping Gimli, leave me be. I got really
annoyed at her and I just farted on her and she just took it. Like, she didn't do anything. She wasn't
like anything.
For Gimli, honestly. Right, so they're getting right in-dict, unfortunately, and then we are
going to move there. I'm going. I'm coming. I'm going. I'm going.
Okay.
Oh, those are prisoners. Silly me.
Is there any dominance through a fart? Honestly, though.
Um,
leave him be.
We would all take it from you. It would- I would like a bite of cake. Oh, she doesn't like to wake me up and I'm like,
um, I purposely, like, I let her in a vehicle outside
for 30 minutes before I go to sleep and I play with them, I feed them, I make sure they're all sorted
and she's just still trying to bite me and I'm like, Gimli, please.
I have such a little sleep as it is. Please be nice to me, darling.
I can't even keep up with you.
Um,
but she's a cootie buttootie. I love her to smithereens. I really do. I love- I got, like, so blessed having
me be going Gimli in my life.
Um.
Ah!
Right. Were we doing it? Were we doing it? Were we going in?
Uh, as I was saying about Azura's birthday stream,
I haven't- so she- she's gonna do origami, like, handcam origami, which is adorable.
Um,
and she goes, I have tons of computer paper
and my brain was like, wow, like, I got warped into a different dimension because I've not heard that term
since my grandparents called it computer paper, not just paper.
Like, isn't paper and computer paper the same thing? Or am I going mental? Mental, like, Oriental.
Am I not supposed to up here yet? Okay, yeah.
Now, the intel is supposed to be up here.
Okay, it's taken. Right. Okay, the game seems to remember when I picked it up before.
Uh, right, let's go, let's go.
Uh, sure. I'm gonna guess the distance.
Now, if you get these three in a row perfectly, you will get an achievement. Ah!
I missed it. I'm getting out of this time.
Hermit, thank you for becoming a member. Please enjoy the emotes.
Um, yes, as I said, AC, Emmy, and
Mercy's emote batch is coming up first. Then, Sheebie is going to get- oh, fuck that one, I don't know.
Um, Sheebie's is gonna get- oh, I'm getting sick. How can I miss this up so much?
Sheebie is getting updated completely to, um, make it reflective of her.
Right, sorry, I shouldn't look away until I can look away.
Thank you again, Hermit, for becoming a member.
Up a bit! I wasn't paying attention. Sheesh.
Um, I don't know how I'm doing so bad. Thank you.
Right, well, and then super tall for this one because it's far away.
Too tall, somehow, even though that looked correct.
Thank you! Jeez!
Sergei had more than enough time to open that weapon, Kashi.
Yeah, sure, yeah.
Thank you very much. I'll take this KS.
Don't need boltcars!
Right, where are you? You're about- wait, what?
Why did that say prisoner on his name?
Who has a farmers? You have an AK-47.
Did you know the AK-47 is the most produced assault rifle in the world?
I don't really know why.
I don't know, maybe it doesn't jam as much as other assault rifles or something.
I like- I'm 99% sure this is the most contracted assault rifle in the entire world.
Aye! Why am I getting RPGs so much?
My biggest thing here is cheap and reliable.
Ah!
But yes, and then myself, Schuber, and- is there- am I supposed to spray this?
What? No?
Yo, what am I getting wrecked by?
Bro, I'm on the Triton recruitment mode, please!
Oh, that was an- that was an accidental aim down sight.
That wasn't supposed to happen.
Now, normally the AI is actually pretty fair in this game,
and if you're not looking at it, there's any Giza.
Give me what's this?
A harpoon to take down a chopper?
Does that really mess up helicopters that badly?
I wouldn't really think to use a harpoon to take down a chopper,
but maybe it would mess it up so badly.
Curious.
But yes, Azura showed her what she's doing,
and her move out goal and everything.
I hope you guys found it enjoyable.
She worked very hard on it, and she's really excited to do it,
and I hope it goes well.
She's been keeping me updated about, like, the-
Would you stop it?
How are you spawning there?
You weren't even there a second ago!
They're spawning on me!
You're cheating!
I'm going to-
I'm going to release her birthday trailer,
and then I'm going to ask management to put, like, money on it ad-wise,
so, like, more people will come aware when it is.
But as I said, we're all doing, like, a collab on her channel right away,
and I think it would be really fun to be like,
oh my god, thank you for the t-
thank you for supporting Azura!
Like, all of us are, like, going nuts over your name,
because she has support Azura.
I just find that really cute and sweet,
like, all six of us, like, oh no!
You know?
Yes, and then she's going to have-
Ah, he got shot at!
No sticky!
It's over, Sergei!
No, I'm so sorry if you named Sergei what you did.
You-
Yeah, it was a worthy sacrifice.
He has made the motherland proud.
Yeah, you're not hiding behind these little panels that much, are you?
Step six.
I watched a bit of her stream, and then she cried.
Oh no!
What did I-
What is it about her-
her pudding?
Someone gifted an artwork with her little pumpkin spice,
and I felt really, it was very sweet.
We never got to tell them how much we loved them,
but I'm so sorry!
Like, how they messed up my boy.
Do I have to leave now?
I thought- No!
No, you're fine.
Oh my goodness, he has so much armor!
I shall announce that I should have pre-
love you, have fun, and have fun fellow-
Love you too, love you too!
Thank you for the super chat, Momolo.
Please don't worry about it!
Wait, why am I to protect him?
From what?
How are they-
I don't even think I've ever-
Oh, checkpoints being reached!
Bro, I can't tell the difference between the enemies.
I'm really bad for it.
I guess the ha, but I don't know.
I always feel like whenever I played Call of Duty,
I always questioned if I was colorblind.
I found the saturation on the colors really hard to, like, differentiate.
Like, I think it's just the way that they've done,
aim, like the game-style type thing, stylistic.
Obviously, it's not exactly supposed to be my little pony,
where it's all sunshine and daisies,
but I just feel like the saturation could be like,
can I have a bit of a couple more color?
Hmm.
Bro, I felt guilty for noticing,
but I know how to be silly, silly closest.
Oh, ow!
Ow!
Don't do that.
That's cheeky doodle.
You're gonna make me fart.
You're gonna make me so nervous.
Whoa!
For me?
When the game calls it the death machine,
rrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrr!
Where's Mason?
Oh, sorry.
Where's Red Snow?
My sensitivity's a bit higher than I anticipated.
Oh, no, you were a prisoner, sorry.
Not him being so close to freedom and I fuck it up because I can't tell the difference.
Why, yes, I'd love to carry the death machine.
Say no more!
For Mother Russia!
this is so satisfying wasn't this not a reward streak I think this was a reward streak I
kill streak and multiplayer if I'm not mistaken but I could be mistaken I could be a dumb
dumb god who was driving that that thing was ready to go outside down just a small bump
in the road that's the hole in the back of the things like vertical oh no not these RPGs
again get away from me I can't see is it you get away from me no I'm not having it
no I'm not having it
we will burn this place to the ground you're great
oh they got me they got me
oh
guys
never left me where is me bro I have the death gun of the death machine we're
not done yet we're not done yet we do not have much time shawnee's cat after
baiting her yes exactly may this be a warning to you Gimli don't think I
wouldn't do it again
freedom well not yet not yet not that part yet not that part yet wait for it
wait for it are you ready to see me drive a bike oh this was such a good
mission I don't care where anyone says this was such a good mission
and it and it has auto aim but which I love they hate us literally we're just
two prisoners oh I guess we're prisoners of war though so it makes us a bit more
valuable than like your average target basically which is understandable good to
know that I have some value me really living up to the stereotype about women
drivers hold on a minute even in video games I cannot conquer the seat right
let's try this again hold on a minute hold on a minute a little to the right
okay a little to the right my death count is two already no don't don't count
that part okay I'm like making sure I stick to the right a bit more than I
did last time okay that's a bit too much to the right you know just want to not
make the same sorry rest up you're my peel rest of go behind me if you don't
want to get buck shots in your back and I'm very excited as well cause in the
girls are gonna get highlight videos of streams that they choose and we're gonna
see how it goes and everyone has picked what they were on my jumping on the
truck do it it's physics even like safe like that don't you just not go flying
off the truck and I am getting a highlight reel of a buckshot roulette I
decided to do because I thought it was in particular a really good stream please
stop shooting me I'm trying to talk about I'm trying to leak failure secrets
stop trying to make me they're trying to stop me leaking failure secrets I can't
believe it I can't believe it I just want to leak everything jump rest of
notice how the truck stops on its own suspect you're trying to silence me
I'll let you can see the achievements are in the top right for something
it was my friend riefling riefling was my friend but he didn't make it up
they tested me they knew I wouldn't break now I'll break now
but the numbers that were playing in the audio yeah the numbers started up when
you were calling me the truck maybe the real resume for the friends who made
a long I'm late but go here and then you go here at the start we just complete
the first mission so we've done the tutorial national security briefing
priority one redirect mason alex to the pentagon congrats if you name's alex alex
mason alex mason
the pentagon I'm wondering when we play Pokemon should I catch Pokemon and name
them after you guys like you anonymously submit your name to me just your
first name I don't want your fucking legal name and address and your appeal
your fucking birth certificate and ships I wonder if we should try that in
Pokemon I just catch Pokemon and then you send me your first name and a
marshmallow and it's just potluck but people are gonna get sour I'm gonna do
okay oh nothing less than our national security is at stake yes sir oh my
contents no we oh dear this is Nikita Dragovich Dragovich
when do I kill him we're lucky to have you back mason yeah oh yeah we're going
down the highway we have an escort by the military police debit card tape
pokemons will go hard what does that even mean
it's a black hook is your I felt like everyone was watching this oh yeah watching
me oh this is how we got out after work I don't think you can trust anyone
sometimes even yourself that's why we're here mason right here 24 7 never
I'm just here to smoke a cigarette please tell him we're here at once
clearance Prospero clearance Prospero
distinguished here I remember I kept hearing numbers
this thing couldn't get them out of my head
area oh I just got an idea
yeah please he's waiting for something boring no maybe not no maybe it was just
there just I'm correct in saying that station has been saved more than once I
have no shame idea okay I mean I could I could record the numbers and try and
break you in the back they're really like touching that stuff a bit too scary
for me I'd rather just hypnotize you into joining and join Pete's paint up on
pizza overwhelming and not yet Defconn five
one cigarette this inner sanctum was built in 1943 we rarely use it and their
sanctum thank you mr. secretary can you tell how three ever sleep okay time to
take a seat oh yeah good afternoon gentlemen oh there's only one
great honor mr. president sit yes master
why are we on slow motion we are in grave danger from the communists our
freedom I might be in my life is at risk put the ink in the bag and no one gets
hurt and by the bag I mean I'm told that you are the very best that we have
anywhere you will need to be yes mr. president sir take care of it yes yes
mr. president sir you have my word sir I promise I'm not a sleeper agent I'm
sorry I got a wee bit brainwashed just a wee bit though
this is a wee tiny witty bit
it's just a storm dick oh yeah these to call it why is it dick is short for
Richard Richard the dick I was that short version of Richard I
didn't know
I should love me I read that Richard Rick dick um I love it I get it but why
would Rick randomly become dick Rick robert robert Bob we shouldn't be obese
so they can't you buy
oh my god that's an MP5k there's like the most common movie gun ever used they're
really used on movies so much sorry sorry oh god red dot say on mine I think
that's gonna help with a buddy recoil you don't listen to crazy can I just can I
just crouch I'm not all the way to the floor I'm pressing C and it puts me all
the way on to the floor I just want to crouch a little bit let's go oh there you
hey I found out it turns out if you press C it makes you crouch Richard is
that because he knew how to use it you're done you're done wait so if your
name's Richard do you only get the title once you've proved that you've had
those oh no don't delete the common I was teasing oh no did you delete your own
speaking of deleted comment do you remember how in the tavern stream report
on my ASMR video I was like oh there is no talk I never put no talking in the
title or anything like that that person deleted their comment and I don't know
if I upset them or not I was kind of tee hee funny ha ha but the comment got
deleted then now I'm scared that I've hurt someone's feelings and I feel really
bad I feel really really bad damn it's weaver he's burnt your colleague is
unwilling to explain his presence in this facility who the fuck is this
surrender now they get deleted by a morn oh you didn't delete it oh I wouldn't
ever delete it myself oh I rarely have to spank my mother really spank bend over
bunk oh no spank no bunk this is not good you're such a sweetheart is running
well just because oh
oh that was that's yeah that's bad I'm going to leave my comment just for the
brainwarp no no cuz you're gonna start making me down I never want to make
anyone feel bad cuz like I just like oh wouldn't it be funny if I like pretend I
thought like they might reply like oh tee he sorry my bad I must have misremembered
or something like that was supposed to be the thing because he deleted the
comment now I'm like oh my god he feels terrible my nose pain I was decent I'm
sorry that I'd mislead you mother sleep type of post whale no the bailar
I sure you my mods are always lurking in the shadow they're like assassins and
assassins creed you don't see them until you're getting stabbed and by stabbed I
mean your common room and by stabbed I mean tamed out for 10 seconds oh my
god I feel so bad I'm going to delete my whole channel now you're gonna give me
brain worms what's going on here
you don't know that's brutal that's brutal that's brutal right time to suit you
into the reservoir 1984 with these numbers I never even connected that
mods with the mod spots car now the mods are always lurking in the shadows
allegedly they've been doing fantastic we've always Russian but he was right
oh my god he looks so out of it wait oh me how long was mason and work it off
or can he like spray it straight up para rossi
difficulty of this game is glad to see you're so good do I guess let you as
well or sorry I was too busy contemplating if I guess we are thank
you tiny spanish yes legendary sorry yes playing get this game on legendary
yeah I'm pro yeah you totally shouldn't go back to the stream and the bar where
I played on my game controller and then I instantly went to mason keyboard because
I miss like it's so much it was so bad I mean I do even know if it's any better
I'm missing keyboard but I think oh we've got more friends okay if it's for
friends who commit war crimes together you is for no humanity and is for
never doing never considering the Geneva convention done in the war zone
location this is awful I know draw attention I will blend in use for
uranium bomb oh yeah that was amazing black yeah like when the screen goes
way it makes you an angel I'm a brother sinful one although look maybe maybe was
a naughty no Mary wasn't annoyed hold on a minute the other one I'm following what
we to do it preview it can't sell off no I didn't wait that wasn't what I'm
supposed to I swear if I'm at the Thai shooting scene I'm gonna cry okay right
let's find I thought I was supposed to kill them sorry I'm too busy yapping my
head off to follow the plot oh my god oh don't you just hate it when a streamer
talks over all of the dialogue in the campaign mode and then doesn't know what
to do at the say oh isn't it just the worst thank goodness I don't do that
whenever I play games I never talk over the dialogue I'm super engaged with the
plot I mean already know the plot to be fair already know the plot so be nice
to me okay this is just a trip down memory lane okay
yeah you know what you mean and is for no survivors huh when the dialogue talks
over the streamer literally oh that was supposed to happen ready oh oh
clearies for before we move up right so that we're here yeah bonk
is that Intel the Intel's like on oh no wait no the Intel's already been picked
up cuz I've been here before deja vu I've been in this place before higher on
the street my time to go wait where's I extended my I'd rather extended mag than
a code to be honest we're sorry my mission is to be a lot higher than what
I'm used to there we go I stand in magna I know stop it stop it stop it stop it
okay thank you strongy you're so awesome yeah you like when I just see
anything that comes to mind and I don't feel or anything yeah is that your
favorite type of stream yeah yeah and I leave you in the hands of faith yeah
everything's actually an assassin's Creed reference wait we're about to go oh
right okay I was like I was like doesn't that mean I've done a 360
by the way mama why you hardly got any sleep maybe here's the next ASMR for you
okay your Scottish GF into letting you tie her up for smexy times but instead you
wrap her in a blanket and make her sleep she angrily falls asleep actually
wholeheartedly I'm down for that I think that would be a really good day
you should roll play I'm down for that honestly watch the truck what truck I'm
see a truck I can't see because of the smoke yes they're gonna have to aim
one of us is the problem here and it's no me no you're not pinned down by what
he's behind the wall I can do that remember not to go down a rope with
your hands or you're literally not even gonna have any skin on your hands that
weaver you look like yeah do you need some help clear right clear left it's clear
able to continue on mission weaver it's do it bro you literally just lost an
eye was compromised as we'll be in subtle move to plan B and it may still be
time to abort the launch we need to get to the auxiliary control bunker I tell
her control bunker I always sleep refund three seconds later I honestly
that is a good YouTube roleplay I like that and disguising I don't know what
would call it though but I definitely think that's called potential that's a
good suggestion thank you thank you thank you what did I just hurt myself on
the laws of gravity what my screen went all red hey why do you guys have AK's
and I have an MP5k what's going on here I'm starting to feel a bit a bit of
favoritism by the CIA shine through what's going on please go up the ladder
why developers make sure when oh I saw a cave I don't want a car go stop giving
me Kogi key I just want a key sorry I know there's a tamer but it's really
important that I get this specific tape of God I want okay I don't even really
still alive quick quick quick we're on a tamer there's only four minutes to go
oh you didn't have to do that you need to make sure you spoil yourselves to be
playing to look after yourself do you understand me why is why is the way
hello I've never seen that happen before I randomly go where chair thank you for
the super chat my why did it do that yeah why aren't you it I mean he must do
something here we spoil ourselves by spoiling you don't think I stayed
the thank you for spoiling me but you have to make sure you spoil yourselves
too yeah damn those of us did we do that or did they already killed them no
matter what oh oh they've destroyed this on purpose
what
in structures unclear sending money I hope I can do it okay thank goodness
instructions and clear send them money thank you now keep your money if you
want to support I'm allowed to be cheeky and be like it's better to support
Azura like even with $5 to help her move I'm allowed to be cheeky like that I
don't know I feel like that's cheeky thank you well whoa wow what whoa I was
how I would say that no wow because wow is w-o-w you're whoa you can be
cheeky as you want if you want to sure yeah and yeah there is a lot of positive
feedback to her donut on which I was quite happy about and I was I'm not
gonna lie I've been worrying about what the response would be etc and being like
oh this is you know this doesn't feel like incentives or this feels like
rubbish or whatever and I was like you know as I said Azura works so hard and
working with me to like pick stuff and especially she definitely took on board
my increment thing and it's just absolutely not dogging on anyone please
don't take it that way for me personally when beachers do donuts on like
without purpose and they have a big gap between stuff I'm I'm just like please
please for the difference of 1000 US dollars I think you can consider
something a bit more okay I'm staring at it oh that wasn't it aim so like she
did fantastic I'm really happy and and she gets a war artwork I'm on to you Azura
I know what you like aim but she did a fantastic extreme with the bleeding
hearts as well and they came up with like stuff they were interested in
together like she's watching an anime for the first time it gets called mysterious
girl well mysterious girl and then I think she's getting a fan art of her
dressed up like the main character of her and the main character I don't really
want to shoot the sign I mean I know the scientists are the baddies but
sometimes you know people the soldiers here are just here for a paycheck you
know they've got mortgages and stuff and kids and how home in that and I'm just
a bullet early in them although actually does the army recommend you not to have
a partner am I going mental no I wouldn't say that's a mental thought sorry I'm
trying to pick this one up it's got extended magnets I'll have to reload as
much excuse me and wait can I just hit fire oh my god the hip fire so good in
this game wait how could I forget I've been aiming properly this whole time I've
been aiming properly this whole time and I could have just been spamming him from
my hip what was in here you just chilling in there that's right aim down
say bros it's over it's over hip fire bros rise up are you an enemy sorry I'm
getting a bit discombobulated hip fire bros rise up now is your time I forgot
how good the things that even this late in the fire he's decided to throw
himself out he literally could have hid and we and walked away but he was like
nah I get paid enough to deal with us it's common for military men to have
relationships weren't down cuz of Jody and his wife back home what's Jody
mommy's hips is strong
I curious he goes out the window hip fire and choirs
rise aim optional literally the aim is optional in hip fire and I say for
place sabotage the show we it's space program any show me it's dim hip shots
don't miss I remember running a niki aki and
firing was so fun I found a family to be the most desirable gun spoke to me on
another level so what you are saying is we should don't know to you as to a
seara just like the others so Azura hasn't as I spoke about this before on
stream so I think I'm okay to repeat the message thank you gaming kids in a
aim she obviously finds it very difficult to make content cuz she lives
with her family type thing and they make it a bit difficult so obviously I spoke
to her I'm like when when we did the interviews with the tips don't lie in
that hip fire don't miss I mean if we're gonna compliment my aim like that
sure sure hey thank you the baby Lord Jody is slang for a dude who takes
advantage of the fact that the military members always only on deployment to
sleep with a spouse a Jody is a guy who takes care of your wife while you're
deployed geez that creates some brain worms in a half if everyone's on about
that in the military bunker Jody this Jody that Jody gonna go for a job Jody's
again it's basically oh no that's even wait imagine going away serving your
country and then I know it's copyright I don't give a shit we're enjoying this
people we're enjoying this one but it's gonna get copyrighted don't care it's
fine for any military personnel to have a partner slash family but they have to
understand it's difficult for them because if the call is made there is a
chance they may not return yeah that's what I thought an ono maybe good to see
you Jason Hudson CIA wait why is the music so quiet hold on a minute get that
shit oh it's not that much larger to be honest on my head set
back to 64 CIA gave a control of corporate operations it's still really quiet yeah
it's quite for me as well well time to say goodbye to the board after this dream
no no no the bottle just get copyright and well it's not gonna get taken down
some yapping over and everything and we can prove that it was licensed by the
video game technically video games are not supposed to be claimed and because
they've been licensed by the producer like the publisher of the thing game so
Vods for game shouldn't be claimed but YouTube hasn't caught up with that it's
just a guy we ran over sorry bud about that didn't mean that sorry old chap let's
get you into the bunker shall we
alright alright alright did you know that a kitchen desktop in Scotland can be
called a bunker like when you ask like if the fruit balls on the bunker and you
like put a board down and cut on it that's the bunker no like I was we ran
over someone else yeah I think they say there's a lot of like in friendly fire
in real life in the military but they kind of cover up because obviously no
one wants to be known for the one who got by
she's no one shot me only me with the the knife
whoo press f f f f f f f f f f f f I'm spamming it
get off me you're not a replaying bunk that's a really cool one I mean oh no
that's terrible no warframes oh no look if he means me harm he's not making it
out alive that's all I'm saying I didn't follow in with highways oh I see you
too late woods if you're gonna go ahead maybe kill them before I walk into the
manually got it what is going on what do you mean adjust my fire move it you
want me to go under if this thing crushes me who is shooting me hold on my
looks like they'd be so high I don't know who's shooting me with injured why can I
I can't reverse under the tank what that's such a random detail you're not
allowed to reverse and wait not a replaying does that mean we get to go
on top of it yeah if you are replaying you get to go on top of me if you're not
a replaying if you're faking then I'm allowed to deploy a grenade and then
pursue a rather rather extreme I do I don't have to confess rather extreme
wait sorry I'm to follow woods are you bugging out am I being a bit too good
all right now no you've given me my mission objective what is this press S
to pick up oh my god everyone must have tonight is in the military I never even
thought about that not yet not yet but I was stuck with holding the thing and
no one gave me cover fire but I give everyone else cover fire boo stinky right
everyone give me cover fire yeah we must deal with the fake links go away fake
links not again no no no no I think I'm dead okay I might win I might win go away
fake you don't actually watch my streams you just see mean things about
go away you upset me wait why is the same damn it we any go sorry let me let me
be grip woods I went hi whoo no why would you do just lay down on the copper
at least seems quick I'm not going crazy or is this actually how the Vietnam War
was I remember and folk being like oh they just kept coming and coming and
coming and it was like oh yeah nice shit you're in their country I don't know
maybe I'm just being dumb I am very low like this okay and it means okay is guys
can you please lay cover fire I'm not being funny I don't have all the time in
the world please lay some cover fire down I'd appreciate that I'm like
literally there's too many fake links right now okay there we go can I have
this back when did I get this bad boy
enough enough
we think cover fire right we follow woods again following wood woody woody
woods I'm following I'm following I'm going around the trenches I'm lagging
behind woods wait for me you're too fast okay we're in out by me my ankle
a chain a leak no thank you but thank you for the offer though it sounds like I
really lovely like Asian dish like would you like to try the chain a leak why
of course a bitch
let's fuck you said a swear word you can't say a swear words we're in the
military we must uphold a good record and make sure everyone feels welcome and
make sure that a life is Gucci Gucci Gucci yeah yeah yeah what's in here
they really want me to use this fine I'll use it what does it do I mean not
that it's insanely better so what I'm supposed to just move in okay okay I need
cover fire need cover hold on reloading hold on let me do my dance while I
reload oh he had last stand on I know second chance it's called yeah I put my
little rule and second chance on black box okay what am I just supposed to be
here I'm just supposed to annihilate the area I'm not really sure sorry look
really tall really fire why is the music getting really intense okay right
teammates I'm gonna need you to start using that AI mmm I know you know where
the enemies are I know you know where the enemies are AI so I'm gonna need you
to start fucking shitting alright I'm gonna need you to start rooting to
make shooting I made myself clear I bet I do mmm I better make myself clear I
don't know why I'm the only one shooting in the down team yeah let me listen
to their dialogue maybe that will give me a hint I'm getting a blight death
number five no no okay so we're supposed to be here for a set amount of
time do what spray and pray yes sir I get guy teammates teammates woods are do
you not have a perimeter do you know what perimeter is I'm starting to feel
like I'm the one that got training and no one else what are you job are you
joking I'm being trolled right now
alright I'm blasting them I don't know I'm supposed to do I assume I'm just
AI can you pick on someone else please I'm begging I'm begging begging you to
off to look on to someone else other than me what about picking woods my teammate
or the random AI I'm moving up I'm moving up I'm moving up I'm moving up I
don't know something's not clicking the trench line I don't know knife the
barrels wait knife the barrels are you trolling these what how is that supposed
to Ken that there's no objective no gonna be actual so for real there was no
objective indicating I just touched those barrels sorry I probably missed the
existing moment in the issue would blow herself up immediately he'll prove
that brah honestly I'm not gonna learn oh player go do this thing but we're not
gonna tell you how to do this thing why yes of course thank you thank you the
beauty lord thank you for the super chat and no no don't say it was in the
dialogue it was very clear don't say it's in the dialogue and it was clear look
I'm a yapper okay I'm gonna yaps through it I don't remember having to push
barrels either when I played this game I don't I know controversial but it wasn't
obvious
okay music good though music good though
ragdoll go away go away
bottom bottom bottom bottom hold on I'm gonna have to reload in a minute you all
better stop spawning in in the second okay hold on I'm sitting in my hole I'm
reloading in my hole leave me alone okay there we go ready
it's just we play I am ready I think anyway are you ready are you ready on
phone say they are spawning every time I look away for a millisecond knock off
okay get that was cutscene or that would have been death number two claiming
these houses are pain old-school games in the show
what's no I was really anti-climactic okay we did it not the jam literally the
flamethrower akd spawns put them don't breathe in the smoke too long you'll
get carbon dioxide poisoning please be careful please exit the tunnel at the
next convenience enter soldiers we enter soldiers we big yen
what I'm fighting I don't know I seem to have unlimited ammo so that I have to
aim hold on a minute this is all bumpily wumpily hold on a minute this is lower
accurate okay okay okay okay okay uh-huh oh yeah let them know let them know let
them know put me back in the regiment she put me
uh-huh corporal corporal put me back in the regiment corporal don't don't rain
me out just yet I know I'm your worst asset but don't
carno carno hi carno ashite mashite what okay okay who driving this you need
to stabilize this I've not taken my anti sickness meds come on did you know
that in the Vietnam War a lot of soldiers came home with opioid addiction
because in war they give like a lot of opioids and stuff to give people sorry
hold on hold on wait where's the other one where's the other one and they give
them to like deal with their nerves and stuff and or like drugs in general like
I think there's there was a report on like heroin like a lot straight up on
heroin because it's so nerve-racking to go into war but I think they used to do
that in the past as well like everyone be like drugged up in somewhere or
another I was rather interesting honestly maybe if I do my drug education
stream we could talk about it
there is morphine in their med kit spamming the valkyrie rockets look I
don't know how much I just cost the government spamming that amount of
rockets and missing but sorry looks don't count break the siege in the
battle of case
hydration check yeah crystal man so Vietnam was a war on drugs but the
wait that's why I don't think it is that what they made the Vietnam war
about they pretended it was about brown ice running chat how are you doing we're
putting your tinfoil hats on about the Vietnam war I don't I think that hard
to believe the it was more of a proxy war with the Soviet Union we would like
to congratulate drugs for winning the war on drugs round of applause to drugs
the war on drugs was unrelated is that how they framed it though no it was
because of the feeding I mean didn't we go in because of a domino theory the
factor no name is a proxy warbook
we're here to yank a defector with vital intel on drug addiction action that's
right and today we're gonna rate cocaine versus heroin all right cocaine
instantly I feel an ego boost
could the tear ranking live as terrible anyway anyway I'm actually I'm
Scottish I'm allowed to make jokes about drugs okay if you didn't know
Scotland has the highest drugs deaths in Europe I think we're all predispositions
due to depression oh my god it's the gun name that you're not allowed to say in
Britain oh you're not allowed to say this gun name in Britain because it's an
insult but I'm gonna say it because I'm talking about the gun and I don't use
this terminology oh my god we have we have flame ammo incinerate ammo that's
bad this gun is called whoa I just about destroyed you me no good life
how are people still in here they're called dragons breath rooms no they
just put people on fire
geez this gun is feral monk oh what drink can we get oh this is cigarette
well we won't use the British terminology for cigarettes either cuz that
would get me done for me I'm actually surprised I've not slipped up on stream
cuz that my obviously it's just normal in Britain and my mom smokes and like we
use that terminology but you know let's say it because everyone thinks oh yeah
according to the US dragon breath is still Kobe wait dragon breath is still
permitted and is not against the Geneva convention hold on sorry I'm shocked is
that real dragon breath is the actual name of the ammo type and it's not against
the convention
we so dramatic the way he fell in hold F to open the door bunk bunk almost sorry
you didn't see that I can't believe that yes doesn't care honestly I should be
surprised I should be surprised should off is anyone surprised
breath rounds contain powder titanium titanium powder is highly combustible
into hot molten metal just imagine what that does to the skin thank you the
beauty lord do you for this super chance I didn't know it was actually called
dragons breath but I mean you know it really is a good way to get around admit
it's just incinerated ammo and you're totally not breaking the convention the
suggestion and I remember learning about that story where a woman and sorry
we're not to go support I'm to support oh you're doing oh you're doing great I
am so proud of you I think you're doing a great job and I know it feels like the
work is never-ending but sometimes being able to push through shows the
resilience that I know you have deep down inside you they're there you're all
supported head pads pat pat pat there we go all the head I think you feel
supported now need more soldiers like starting for real I think I'm I'm gonna
see something controversial if who oh why did that scare me please leave me
alone oh oh my god he got he got fades he got fade wait he actually got fades he
got oh my gosh I am here with you're making me emotional blackouts positive
affirmation starting please this is war that was pretty controversial I go I
came for over it again and his influence spreads like a cancer even the
Kremlin does not know what he is truly planning my boy is back guess who's back
back back back again get me raise those back back back don't tell a friend friend
friend guess he's back in my head with the numbers and he's dead
I created a sleeper agent because nobody wants to be mason no more I'm chopped
liver I'm back brainwashed by the Russians no no no no no I tried I so hard
to do that off the top of my head think at the same time take radio oh we have
extra wait so they're gonna give it to regular soldiers but they'll give it to
me oh we got Huey with the RT taxes Huey gone ship you know we got 10 kill
streak for that I'm to support the time oh no alright whoa whoa whoa whoa I'm
burning I'm burning hold on a minute I'm on fire she's getting a little hot
she's getting a little hairy yeah cuz I'm special forces I'm special forces
all right you don't have to tell me twice thank you thank you
there's soldiers on fire there's soldiers on fire oh what the controversial thing
I was gonna see is tag on with what these I'm not gonna make it okay I think
I'm okay there's another target I'm not even got my Huey back up yet oh oh they
get them that's right smoke them that's right get them yeah wait can you say
that on YouTube wait what did I say stunning and brave opinion all right
no no right controversial opinion I'll finally see it so Ken if you've got a
barracks in that and it's like all guys isn't the best way to keep morale up is
to like give them the opportunity for a good shag like isn't that not how you do
I don't know like oh you chase Louise Woods he's right in front of me you're
scaring me wait what is going on let me wait see to crouch sorry tell myself how
to do these controls right stop spawning in this building you keep spawning
behind me this is my target I can't even I can't even see the target out out
out I'm getting involved hold on I'm just I'm just trying to go do something I
don't know do something helicopter please I beg but I'm begging
big conjugal visits for soldiers there's also women on base the barracks
but is that what the terminology is for women a barracks bunny so what's a guy
called that gets shagged on in a in a military sit and did they get a name too
I mean and wars are wording oh maybe not that part are we fling lucky he's the
same name a bro okay okay I didn't realize I didn't realize sorry I'm
I'm present oh I'm too busy distracted by the idea of a barracks bunny
VTuber hold on a minute barracks bro oh wait we'll give him a name we flings in
the barracks a real mercy answer but what would the snippets version be hold on
let me real hold on let me let me a pair shoes in a second I just need real
of course oh mercy your emotes have been ordered ordered I've forgotten to put in
the update spam that I've ordered your emote I told the reeflings first before
I told you that I ordered your most I'm sorry I'm a failure I'm sorry thank you
moment yeah I sent it away and you know the emote I'm not gonna say it but you
know the emote that is a two-parter they were like you're only ordering this
many emotes and I was like no no no it's there look look at the reference sheet
open your eyeballs there's two different emotes for that emote okay please open
your eyes landing zone I wonder how messed up the lungs of soldiers are just
like all this all this stuff they have to inhale I play pool like mercy well I
was like a technically to even though it's together yeah they when I sent it
off they were like because I said the number of emotes and they were like no
that's not how many is in the reference sheet and I'm like please open your eyes
kind blue you even listed them like a separate emotes in the names like you
gave them two names and I'm like yeah pick up explosives press raise my button
to throw and then left my splint you're ready for this
is this literally they're coming from the smoke grab claymores was there claymores
I even see claymores oh sugar there was I love these I loved playing with claymores
because people would get so mad in search and destroy if they died to a
claymore it was the funniest thing ever I loved it I genuinely loved it it was
so fun how do I select the C4 I think this is just a timer I'm just to survive
the waves I am on break after six hours of work five more go yeah listen catch
a bit stream I hope you're enjoying your break make sure you hydrate though
because it's tiring work like you don't know I think they say if you feel
thirsty you're already really dehydrated or something like that I don't know like
some people pee clear some people pee yellow and some people pee apple juice
color now I need to figure out which one starting invoking devil man and team
quite it too yeah I said we're gonna play overwatch two next week but I
accidentally scheduled something wrong I might need to I might need to put it
woods why are you hating up here do you need more support again there there
sometimes life will can be hard but if life was easy would you appreciate the
character development you might unironically go through because honestly
honestly you don't get life experience until you go through harder stuff or
stressful stuff or stuff that isn't stuff that makes you uncomfortable and is
how you like call six for air support you have to you know what my what target
this the biggest time I don't know about you by Pete almost clear hydrate oh yes
of course the ball I know about the boat to the boat as I'm getting absolutely
spanked I'm in give me in give me in okay I'm in the boat oh cuz cool guys don't
look at it I'm a bit of a apple juice unfortunately isn't clear pee bad I don't
know how you gonna stream the whole campaign today absolutely there's no
breaks on this called train today we are a SOG rules so thanks for giving me
research idea well over six research in tinkle paint clear means you are how do
you drink more water moment I am I've almost finished half a bottle of water
today do you know how much more water that is than I normally drink insane
amount I almost ended up with heat stroke doing your work in the desert not
fun time yes please be careful we fling I'm already doing better looking after
myself I've had more water than I usually do I've got a home cooked soup coming up
and I'll either make it today or tomorrow today I might have to focus on the
patreon audio cuz I've not uploaded mine yet don't worry all the girls has all
their schedules up and the sheebie and dessert club is coming on the very last
of the month and me I'm coming right now damn you don't like that she I'm
supposed to be like some sort of pun sometimes I'm gonna take a vitamins a
pee highlighter yellow yes oh my gosh I used to literally take these and they
made it like look as a AIDS oh my god this is messed up torture please close
your eyes if you do not like torture
ooh
ah yeah did you know you can put a light bulb in your mouth but you can't take it
out apparently I don't get that in my head
vitamin B2 turns it neon I'm most of you know damn top crows
pee that's golden like the sun golden brown textures like Mercy's piss on
vitamins oh no not bright golden yellow color palette like Mercy's vitamin
I was so you get the thundergun so thundergun on and other
colleges Nova 6 Nova 6 here it is oh well well this isn't Mustang and oh god
this is awful can I not aim with these
oh I was supposed to break the cat of the thingy well beautiful song thank you
I totally made it myself it's completely mine custom made yes you're
welcome to have copyrights that's not an issue yeah I'm not really a fan of the
oh my god this is awful I need a better gun though I'm not throwing that back
I've no got the timing for that okay there you go I'm sorry I just saw the
throwback and I'm like throwback my phone back okay we'll pick up this bad boy
oh I didn't even saw him in there geez I would have been I'm honestly a terrible
wait I'm I supposed to go out here no I'm not up the stairs up the stairs I am
going up the stairs enemies oh we're in the city of Tyre I love this map this
was a really good map I think it was a DLC map though for the multiplayer which I
didn't appreciate I don't like when they do that I don't know oh no this is a
jump oh my god it's the channel 5 news what is in the
beach of renews sphere oh my goodness Azura has a donut on on the 24th that is
fun I'm gonna show up for that I'm gonna put that okay sorry yes yes yes
college sorry sorry right guns guns guns guns g11 g11 yes yes yes yes yes yes
and then you can't take this I'm gonna use this China Lake this is a bunch of
mummy throwing a baggy is it bad that I have played code for years and I've
never played any of the campaign no it's not bad if you prefer like multiplayer
and getting like the rewards achievements etc all that kind of thing no no
like don't ever feel bad for your game choice like I literally why oh sorry I'm
very small-brained and don't ever feel bad for like just enjoying how you play
games I am I am very much over the lake I don't know if you guys remember the
Xbox and PlayStation and days where it was that wasn't even like OT he just
a wee bit I needed sunglasses for that one college a black ops only game where
you need sunglasses to play because honestly what was that I was blamed for
so long I mean hey I'm scared I'm scared help me weaver and Clark yeah weaver and
Clark help me I'm skilled now you're supposed to aim ball oh this music's
feeling it though well like this one well I'm here for it this is the one
this is the one this soundtrack is if what my my controversial thing was you
know how a base gen one off of sonic heroes hear me out what about base gen
two on one video game each and you guys have to figure out what one is and then
if no one figures out I'll get one of the girls to do a pre-made short about
it so oh no the citizens brah imagine paying taxes all your life and then
you're just like war folder I'd be region honestly I'd want a tax refund all
I'm saying is that imagine if one girl had a college a black ops version of
their frickin song it will be elden right I'm absolutely baby to the upward the
paint oh geez spider-man spider-man does what it I saw that on the way down and
that was the creepiest thing I have ever seen I had like a visceral reaction
like the blood ran cold to that did you see that on the way down that was
terrifying wait what my den weaver these guys that who you want me to go for
sorry I'm gonna pay attention oh we're going down okay we're going down I made
it weaver I'm in the right location I'm walking on the I'm walking on rooftops
why I'm walking on rooftops in the city of Kowloon that no longer exists because
they tore it down but it was the most densely packed populated area ever
recorded in history and I don't think they're ever doing it again because I'm
so glad I have like the ability to sponge so many bullets because it would be
over for me if I was playing there and I never did look up gameplay of Halo and
Baron I should wait was I not supposed to be here open the gate hold on I'm
getting a memory have I gone too far ahead I could have sworn they open a
gate for me oh look it's me on the telly over there you watching me oh no it's
I think my teammates have bugged out because this gate is supposed to be open
to me mommy broke the game again at the exact same location the last time I
played this game I'm like 99% sure I'm gonna have to reset the whole level how
did I bug oh I found it until now he's no coming is a come here open the gate
I'm too stupid to open it please I can't progress without you coming down
I don't even know where you are you must be stuck on the wires I think we start
the level
and what you say money when we're green itself oh shit oh you're sorry no you're
sorry I could have made it I'm so sorry I don't think we lost that much progress
I was kind of just farting about through that I am so sorry I think maybe we were
like right I don't know reefland was too strong no you did there's another one
yeah I would cook a granite for you I'd restart the level for you just open the
gate did you hear the rumor the is it it's a Bruno Mars is like 50 million
dead to the casinos big gamble big gamble always win then apparently he made a
song with Lady Gaga or something like that I've never even dealt with him
another chance for thunder gun though wait are you trolling me is there
actually a thunder gun that I don't know about how could this happen I made my
mistake and I honestly I don't remember ever running into glitches a biochemical
weapon I'm sorry I didn't mean to let me pop these canisters real quick pop in
the canisters pop in the canisters I need the dialogue for Nova 6 yes oh no
they're down to Nova 6 they're the baddies if you throw grenades at the end of
the hallway then grab the black cast set tape at the back on the right in the
small corner room then when you progress into the weapon room it comes up down
here it's an Easter egg how have I never learned about this before oh shit I
died to Nova because I tried to go back down the stairs okay I'm a dumbass
are you ready to watch the campaign all over again okay I'm not fucking around
with that let's just let's just get to it I'm sorry I'm done please open the hatch
please open the hatch I'm sorry please open the hatch how do I even use
grenades gee this throw a nade down into Nova is that what you mean oh the way
weaver I don't think so grab the cassette tape shit shit hold on hold on
right okay hold on no we're gonna grab the cassette tape throw a nade down the
thingy and grab a cassette tape behind me right okay got it got it sorry sorry
for the blinding light I know right throw a nade G for grenade got it and then a
black tape a black tape a black tape yes yes you you yes Intel acquired surely
that's what they mean surely copium that's what you mean right that's what
you mean right surely surely that was cassette tape yep mm-hmm yep oh yeah
okay I'm going up I'm going up I have the Intel acquired it's behind you that
wasn't it I have to do that again be honest I have to do it again
he shot me through the window oh they are another shit me from over there that
wasn't it okay into the gas nice one more time to get blinded everyone put
your sunglasses on I'm very slow me when I inhale Nova six okay a black
kid hey babe I don't think so no oh give me the thunder down don't you think
your government's most of brutality intimidates me you clearly don't know
anything I'm trying to legit right I'm not moving off until I get this thing hi
Gami are you helping me torture this man are you witness to this man Gami okay
a little up we get it bonk give me the answers to I just gonna have an epilogue
this but honestly there's thunder in my eyes through them grenades until all the
canisters expel gas and then grab a tape okay I've been handed across every corner
of the globe they know everything you know they're probably on their way now why
why doesn't like loose ends I've never even dealt with him directly
I was hired to help stabilize the tape is between the money counter and the
monitor around the corner on the table spam spam a little spam a little more okay
it is between the money table money I'm not moving until I get this fucking black
tape I'm about to look up a YouTube tutorial don't think I won't how's the
fuck am I yes the first table oh shit I don't need to look up on YouTube I'm
doing this terribly wrong oh wait the game lets me remain black how's it we are the
table you saw earlier we'll have a little animation of the tape coming out this
one the white table the white table you that looks like it that looks like it
moves don't worry I got no I got all the time that that one yes okay I've got
all the time in the world to make this work give me that fucking thunder give
me that fucking thunder break that one there's only two canisters I can
physically see give me are you moving did you move
I'm been directing the third is in the back you know what else is in the back
my pussy right one more time one more time you already grabbed it I got it wait
I never wait I'm not being dumb right when it opens up I've picked it up got it
open up open fucking sesame me open sesame no right okay at least I understand
now I mean we're getting somewhere right we're getting somewhere hold on hold on
we're getting somewhere okay when it opens up when it opens up it's mine I'm
gonna get it I'm gonna get it I'm gonna pop that right now I'm gonna pop that
one did I pick it up I don't see it I don't see it I don't see it but I opened
up so surely I have it surely I have it it popped open okay I have it I have it
give me your gun now what how did I get the fleamin wafer yeah you have it okay
now what I do it's gonna be in the weapon cashew behind the fridge yeah
getting feral over a video game because it's not doing exactly what I want what
stop it just die oh you're hurting you hurt my feelings okay let me use the the
capiris I should we bet low I should we bet low holy fuck you're too low dude I
don't think I'm allowed to say that hold on hold on a minute I don't think I'm
allowed to say that joke that was enlightening do you know how long that
took me I think that took me like 15 minutes okay I got I got a cheeky
shot and right give me the freaking thunder waffle stomper 9000 okay right
sorry as I said okay Azura 12 hour donathan on the 24th on Saturday of
August 20 24 move out fund got it okay give me where is it am I being
trolled whatever you say English where's the waffle stomper am I going mental
any waffle stop is it supposed to be on the wall yes or no there there cat press
no RPG specter turn 180 there's a knife what about this hello
blamin buffer channeling stop right I'm I'm not touching the thing until you tell
me what to do I ain't touching a damn thing until you tell me where this gun
is put the cassette in the player in the left put the cassette in with E no with
F okay aha how is anyone supposed are they radio signaling it in
okay I already need a real
okay I guess then I can't find any more ammo do you know how long it took me to
get you I'm already gonna run out of ammo in five seconds yeah no flashbang
this time I'm gonna power trip now do you how long it took me to get this I
mean carry them gonna run out of ammo I'm gonna take this to the end of the map
with me I'm taking it to the end of the map with me cuz I love it so much oh no
your citizen sorry okay now let's make sure I don't go too far ahead of the
enemies right don't go too far ahead make sure the enemies at the allies
actually tell me what to do you know we should try that game that has bumping
music but like you have to not get shot in it my brain wants to call this game
hotel tango to I know for a fact the game is not called hotel tango to but
do you know what game I mean where it's like pixie and there's the music's
really well done I'm just sitting here until I feel a bit better
hauling Miami yeah hauling Miami it go like really well reviewed music I'm
wouldn't complete it cuz I suck but the music is like reminding me but I think
I don't know how long it's supposed to actually take but I never was able to
complete the game right I'm gonna wait until you jump down like a monkey and
then I'm a monkey too thank you the booty Lord cut a pop is was cute and I
didn't get you should have hauled my army I think you'd like more I play
buckshot okay so edit it okay there we go that didn't happen last time that
didn't happen that didn't happen last time and now it's happening
you're all mountains yeah man yeah man talk
okay they look ready they look animated and ready yeah checkpoint reached okay
okay we didn't glitch out this time I don't know how I did it last time I'm
just sort of glitching okay there we go nice and easy please open the door for
me cuz I can't do it I my hands are too delicate and dainty and tiny that I
can't figure out how to open it okay thank you
what about you are you ready mommy child lock is on you laugh but I
struggle fucking get into my my iron supplement tablets cuz they have the
click balls cuz I have to get the like high-grade ones so for some reason they
put it behind the click one where you have to push down and go click click
click and then spin it I can hardly again that damn thing I'm like let me give
up goddamn iron supplements jeez oh he's hurting me oh he's hurting me
I'm being mean I'm to go down yeah sure I'll go in here whoa whoa whoa I'm
reloading I'm reloading hold on hold on hold on hold on I'm reloading relax that
was a really cool that was a really cool scene for me to not shoot in how did
I replenish my thunder gun ammo this game is sneaky it must give you more at
certain locations but how would I know what those locations are oh you sneaky
sneakerton or maybe it gave me a good way did I die did I die
oh no I don't want to hurt the fishies no the fishies leave the cuttlefish alone no
it's okay they still have life hold on wait wait you guys go ahead I'm just
gonna pick them up and put them in this tank here okay I just need to pick them
up and put them in the tank they need to live their little fishy lives out oh I'm
trying to help the fishies you don't believe in supporting the wildlife the
marine life and the Marines Marines and marine life yeah you should support them
ooh I want this okay checkpoint to reach okay now what I am yeah
she ate so no I saved you wow Chinese family my first okay I will cover you
very terribly cover you oh my god it's been iron gunner I'm so good I don't know
so they sent in structures in German sorry Bitte Bitte the only thing I know is that
Bitte means like 16 different things and I'm on and I'm on yeah okay I did I did run
across and jump oh I saw it is it because I'm have a heavy weapon okay run jump no I don't think
that's quite correct darling I think you're a wee bit confused I actually have
the 4k footage of me running and jumping again for the third time all right
darling that's more like what I'm talking about you're not telling me what I'm
not doing when I can I'm doing it so didn't give me that attitude again you
understand me black ops mmm didn't say that
well we ain't getting the key rip oh no you know that reminds me of the legal
lord of the rings when they put boring we're done like bingo but starting your
food just 1080p gosh darn it okay I am made up and I'm such a fake yeah my off
playing Assassin's Creed out here you guys are playing caught I'm playing
Assassin's Creed wow I have eagle vision oh my bum good thing I have cake why
would I pick up I don't know why it offered me a pistol right there I did
it oh it's hurting me from behind oh they're getting my butt cheeks help help
I'm stuck get up why get up get up Mason where we headed oh my god please take
me take me they were hurting my booty this name's not the dumpy yeah my boy
broken English escape this cowlun the city of cake that a Mason no I'm Mason
isn't your baby what you wanted exact I was shot in my booty I wonder what came
to scare scarring you get if you get shot in the butt fixated with numbers
drag of it she's second in command crevchenko tested in vietnam on them on
us on his own he didn't care you were Hudson in that mission I think oh you
mean that small detail that I should have paid attention
no just the bill it will listen to me just missing his butt cheek me far away
but I don't think she's dying up crevchenko all of us die but he told me what
they did getting shot in the but we're 50 cal and you don't have a buddy yeah
I agree I don't know how you would stitch together the booty one of the
darkest missions well I'm glad I'm not gonna get flashbanged anymore thank you
was a musician
during the German
oh
many of the great nationals composes we're getting back to my country man it was
a simple hope to the Germans it was a simple device even now is
but it's just ricochet off mommy's body like a sling okay maybe a little bit
slim girl
no vibrating with anything sees a betrayal of a train against all of mother
dragon crevchenko will not travel by such a man
they look only to advance their own interests
is this the ship mission and the snow
is
everything is loaded they are waiting
it is time it is time time to hunt down the last remnants of the flash is right
okay so we are is not enough fun are you squinting me right now and I have fought
it's getting late here have fun with conch so much memories and please get some proper
sleep have fun everyone bye-bye thank you very much and it's 188 for the super chat
yes I will get sleepy bye-bye soon team and I have got confirmation that the
audio master is going to be in play on the first of next month so then I have
less and less responsibility yes don't worry my sleep will come back I also have
a lot of a smart uploads are coming to make up for my a smart debt my death
base I'm glad to enjoy college today I enjoyed too we might give modern warfare
to a play through think of this is a bonus mission from call of J world at war
I don't remember much of that campaign I'm not even sure if I saved it audio master
like for editing a mix and know someone who is gonna take the audios from the girls
divided between the audio edit and team and then upload it to patreon with the
correct tags the strip descriptions etc so I don't touch I don't touch the
scripts I don't touch the audios I just do a things for myself and the reef links
like I'll make more scripts and stuff and with you guys and so I have having like
no for I went from a lot of responsibilities to like no responsibilities
within the span of three months and and it's very nice that you know we could you
know Avengers assemble a team basically and I'm very happy sleep is for the week
but how do you know so everything is coming up strongy and by coming up
briefly you already know where I was going I don't know why I pretend like I'm not
trying to like build a joke up to something like that I don't know why I
pretend we need to stay in our lives see like we have gone accurate the motion
that I can't believe we don't have the one M1 Garand shot and behave your shot and
who is the enemies the way is the enemies
oh actually I remember a little bit I'm stuck I'm stuck on the fence hold on
let me go inside the trenches I'm in the trenches with this one
I didn't realize how much detail they put into that game I mean they easily
didn't have to make sure it was like time period correct guns and stuff but
honestly hats off like as much as you can shit on cod for like always repetitive
or whatever like I don't know sometimes you have for the gems you have to give
props to the gems that are gems like you have to admit I'm solidity are they
trying to go away oh he was coded to die I saw you spawning you naughty boy I saw
you spawning oh no that was a piece of fabric sorry I'm shooting fabric I
don't know I just felt like a threat okay I just felt like a threat the fabric
is scaring me I'm scared it's a ghost that's what it is it's a ghost
oh you can't shoot me I'm through a chain link fence you can't shoot me oh look at
them moves oh I'm so scared oh serpentine serpentine you can't get through
chain link fence oh my god what was that insult about chain link fence it was
like your teeth are so fucked up that you could chew an apple through a chain
link fence or something like that wild insult right what am I doing in here I
don't know I just follow the I follow the oh no I'm gonna hurt myself I need to do
the stairs like a normal person press forward to target motor strikes where
on this oh my god I know why you said this feels like a world at war bonus map
these is world at war assets and oh my god I couldn't have been any more of a
stereotype there something shiny such a fucking woman honestly distracted by
something that looks like jewelry I actually got baited death 14 this
can't be cannot be I'm not supposed to do was it for no oh I'm using Willy
Peaks to see what my target is who should me so knock it off knock it off
are you in a spanking was that not what oh stop it we're in but I'll hit fire
twice as hard I'll aim but even harder I'm aim button so hard all over your face
right now we counting now I mean a little bit what was that other game you guys
are counting my deaths and I was gonna embarrass I can't remember what it was
I am oh wait hold on oh my god I will do many things but okay we don't hurt people if
they give up as long as they don't mean us harm we don't mean them harm we must
oh they really said no survivors and war okay maybe I'm a bit too caned I'm
like well if you don't want to fight anymore and you understand that it's
just for a paycheck I'm not gonna kill you you know just give me your guns and
then oh I just did it I just did the opposite of what I was saying my actions
do not reflect my words I'm a dirty dirty liar I'm sorry I didn't mean it I
didn't mean it all your recent calm like your comrades are really close to me
you're scaring me panzer Hans they have the puns are oh yeah
is it them in Bafa oh press four for something
no tires I'm gonna be so for realsies I don't know how motor strikes are
successful without major casualties like back in the old days where it was like a
manual field thing like it isn't like tech
melodically like super advanced or anything it seems rather I did it again
why do you give up in like five seconds stop if you're gonna shoot shoot
big aside I come on AI you can do it I believe in your AI I keep choosing
violence but I don't mean it I don't want to hurt them some of them give up I
want them to go back home to their families I want them to go home and
play like Pac-Man or something because that game would have been out by then did
you know that Nintendo was founded in 1894 and it was a card game I think
that's how what year it was founded I'm guessing wait oh we drop a grenade no
monkey
do not point that weapon at me Russian dog
sorry I tried to an orphan a moment at the same time and it came out was like
I tried to morning park at the same time what's up fine I said like one of those
poor dogs are like like a Pomeranian like a wee ankle bit are are we rats they're
called rats in Scotland if it's a wee dog it's called a rat oh and dogs are
called dogs in Scotland you know what I should make a YouTube short about all
the slang we have like bunker and what is here that is so important
dog children and babies are called weans and what other words can I think
my bit means your house an empty means a party where the parents are not at the
house for all the person hosting the party and empty because it's empty the
parents aren't there a job he's a shite a towel to tell a lie we tell them
I mean
why
tell me more about your association with the gifting why did we give Steiner a gun
and not handcuffs is he a good ear about the solution what do you call
tourists that visit fallen just tourists have they got a specific name that I
don't know about Steiner's a good boy now boy he's a good boy he's you to be
standing good in boy yeah you do be scooched yeah okay we're using a handheld
porch he's a really lithium Barry's easy why they hanging themselves oh I don't
like this good a young good to be fine good good a young young yeah to be I'm
trying I'm trying so hard
everyone's a bad guy what but me and my men oh wait all three of them are
together I don't know resin of metal three of them but it was too late I am so
dumb I'm so sorry and a Russian flag I am so dumb all three of them are together
met all three of them that's why he hates them even me and my man this is it
right now open the door oh dear well that's a classic wheel turning dot mp3
that is used when we could run we have found what we were looking for
more for cities the German weapon of mass destruction now belong to mother
Gershaw also it seemed our victory was to be short-lived
Dragovich wanted to see the effects are you squinting me right now no it was also
an opportunity to remove a thorn in his side I have long long of their distrust kind of
all he believes himself
Oh my god.
Well, we know why he doesn't like all that much, huh?
Thank you for the, uh, Super Shadow Boogaloo.
That was so sad.
So we got in here, and now we have to frickin' battle.
Are we against the bridge?
Who? You.
The British are coming. The British are coming.
Monk, monk.
Ah!
What?
What? So like they slipped away with the, the, the billet as a...
The recipe to make Nova 6.
Stop dropping down! Go home!
Go home! Go, go back to whatever part of London you came from.
Jeez.
Go away.
Oh! There's a timer now! Goodbye!
I'm not dealing with any of this. Bye.
Where'd I go? Where'd I go? Where'd I go?
The pipe! The pipe! Ah, by the way.
Yes, of course I climbed the pipe.
Let me up the pipe. Let me up the pipe!
Let me up the pipe.
How'd I get up the pipe? What?
Okay. Okay.
Okay, I figured it out.
Let's figure it out.
Right, let's go, let's go, let's go, let's go, let's go, let's go, let's go.
This place is going to blow. You guys don't want to be here.
I promise you, I'll just lead C4.
Guys, please evacuate at the next possible moment.
I planted C4 and I admit it.
I have planted C4. I have planted very severe.
Big boom. Boom.
I don't know if that translates into English
because I'm speaking Russian right now technically.
Big boom.
Big boom. Boom.
Boom.
You all want to get off the ship.
Evacuate the ship at the nearest exit point on the ship.
You would like to evacuate.
I'm away. Bye. It's your problem now.
Whee!
Can you do that by hand if the rope is frozen?
I suppose he has gloves on so it doesn't count.
Oh, are we going alright?
I planted it from falling into the hands of the British.
Bunk!
Right on my forehead.
It was only after I was captured.
Oh, let's translate it for the brief.
Big ship is going to...
Big boom in it. Yeah?
Get me now, fam.
I'm going to get up and run at that point.
Man.
I'm listening.
Yeah.
Give me a tin foil hat.
There's no...
I will be one with you.
Steiner.
Man.
Must die.
Someone's never healed.
Escape the pair.
Should I keep panting like that?
What the...
Did you know when you get a military exam?
If it's a lady and you get a bonbon
she'll flick your tip out of nowhere
to stop the blood full gun from there.
You're welcome, Nino.
Yo, that PNG ready? Huh?
If America ever got their hands on a weapon like that
you know they'd use it.
Oh, that's such a good way to say it.
What?
Cucumb...
Is that a pickle or a cucumber emoji?
Cucumber spank, basically.
Stop it!
It's turning me on!
Nah, we're playing Call of Duty.
Don't get turned on.
Maybe I can palvel of you to get
blood flow if I pan.
Please excuse me for being a ghost.
They ain't loaded in yet.
You've already done that.
What's happening?
Congrats for your names, David.
My leg! I'm bleeding!
I need some help here!
They're coming!
Can you open up? Wood's a bit faster?
I think you have to be fully submerged
in order for doors to be open under water.
Come on, Woods.
Waitin' on you, buddy.
Can you take over? Alright, Dad London,
you mind me?
I'm spammin' it!
I like how the first time I played this game
I never noticed the numbers every time he showed up.
Okay.
Time to perish!
I love hipfire!
Oh, no, I don't...
Well...
Where are we going?
Where am I going?
I don't know what to do.
Am I supposed to go where he is?
I think so.
Oh my god, underwater ragdoll physics?
Okay, yeah. I'm to go up, River.
Got it.
The bullet went invisible.
Anima bullets!
Me when I miss all my targets.
No, no, no. I want the AK.
I prefer the AK. I like it.
It's a staple in any war zone!
That's terrible!
But it is.
Sometimes you can't just see things that way.
Got my knife, yeah.
RPGs, AK on steroids.
The recoil is too much for me.
I'm like a baby recoil.
The AK!
No noise, got it.
Got it.
Swimming in the rain.
You want to do it or am I doing it?
Am I doing it? Fine. I'll do it.
Jeez, since you want to...
I don't know how we're doing this.
I hope I don't drown by the time I get there.
Oh my god!
Oh my god, eel vtuber confirmed for Jentu.
Surprise!
See, I win when we're in the water.
Because I am a water vtuber.
Who's that vtuber type?
It's a water type!
Fuck!
Okay, where now?
Oh, I see him.
Eels creep me out.
You wouldn't want an eel girl
to wrap her tail around it.
And then...
Because she can ear lick it at the same time.
Wait, where am I going?
Give me my mom.
Uh...
Yes, yes.
Croft gen.
The hornets.
It shocked me today.
That would be epic.
Oh, you have a point.
Pachinko! The head Japanese Gamba game!
Did you know?
It's illegal to Gamba in Japan.
So in order to get your earnings,
you like get a gold token
that's worth money or something to get around it.
Rather strange, honestly.
Destroy the ZPU,
place C4,
mission of...
Don't mind me boys, I'm all for this one.
See, I'm in my element in the water.
You guys, you have to hold your breath and stuff.
Me?
Did I start drowning there?
Wouldn't you be glad to see me or something?
I don't know, she's got fun with the same.
I've been bitten so hard by an eel,
I had to go to the hospital.
How are you in a...
situation
that an eel got to you?
I'm too scared to swim in open water.
Why are they still drowning in a Nuzlocke stream?
I'm doing Pokemon soon.
Pokemon's on the roster.
And then Pokemon will be...
I know...
Generation 3 born.
Okay.
I don't need a small amount of war crimes.
I recommend it.
Although, I feel like everything becomes...
a little bit more...
Although, I feel like everything becomes like...
permissive in terms of like...
Oh, that's dangerous.
Silently take out three...
VCs.
Voice chat.
I won't let me in the water?
Oh, because I don't have to go in the water.
Achievement.
Let me open this gate.
A water gate.
Terrible.
Let's hide.
I'm hiding in the water.
They don't see me sneaking.
Ooh!
I mean, I am safe in the water.
Dandan.
Chickens!
Over on the farm.
Hi, chickens!
Would you like to...
Oh, no, your roosters.
The roosters don't lay eggs like hens.
It's time.
I have the fire skin on the commando.
I'm not that I'm showing off a multiplayer skin.
So you can get...
How do you guys always have RPGs?
Aren't those...
Aren't RPGs expensive to manufacture?
How does everyone afford weapons?
Okay, let's play it a wee bit more safe.
As much as it pains me
to hold back from Rootie2e
shooty aimbot.
Oh, no, this is survivor.
Sorry. I didn't realize there was...
villagers.
Okay, let's not hurt the villagers.
The villagers...
Oh, I got the RPG guy.
That was him. He was the one...
No, we had to start walking
in front of my bullets.
I swear.
That's all they want to do.
See, you just did it again.
And then you're going to blame me.
Why am I getting the blame?
I'm a good...
war person.
I try and give people the benefit
of the doubt when they're springing and preying, okay?
Also me who walks right in front of the E.I.
Ooh! Ooh!
I'm not throwing it back.
Sorry, I'd rather let it explode.
What am I to do?
Charlie on the right!
Give me this. Give me it.
You see it? 1-0.
Next is empty. Objective clear.
This seems like overkill
for a wooden bolt.
Come on. This is overkill.
Isn't it?
Isn't this just a way back to...
Oh, this main?
Here is clear.
Okay, okay.
What am I doing?
I'm going this way. Why yes, of course.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa!
Something's pushed me forward.
Who's pushing me forward?
I got pushed into that gunfire.
I got pushed.
That doesn't count as a death animation.
Ow! I've been freaking spawned in properly.
Fuck you, bitch.
Only 15 deaths.
Come on, you so saw me getting pushed forward, right?
I'm not going crazy.
Because you think I'm crazy.
But I'm actually...
Just a war killer.
What?
I'm getting obliterated.
Do not block that grenade, I'll cry.
Right, how about what do you use to it?
Who's always me?
Sorry, how is it always me?
They wonder, they're like,
oh, Mason, you're the best soldiers we've ever had.
I am the only one aiming,
that's why you cheeky.
Cheeky bam.
Cheeky wee bam pot, honestly.
Look at that hipfire aimbot, come on.
Cut, you think Bowman has that hipfire aimbot?
No, he doesn't.
No, he doesn't. Cheeky.
Absolutely cheeky.
Right, we're going in the whole reeflings.
Time to loop up.
And before you, like, what are you on about?
We're going in here, okay?
We're going in here.
Right, oh.
Now when I say,
I wanna, like, annihilate your hole.
I don't mean it that badly.
Our grenade is a bit much.
Whatever.
Into the tunnels.
Oh, the numbers.
Okay.
Did you...
No, press shift
to turn on the flashlight.
I have.
Ooh.
Oh wait, this glitch happened
last time as well.
Not fair with the little.
The, the shaders
break.
They, like, completely break.
What the fuck's wrong with you?
Like, he's not...
I don't know.
I don't know what broken he...
It's coming.
It's with dad. We got V.C. calling all over.
Amen. Amen.
Did I get him killed? Cause I was mucking about with my flashlight.
Do you monitor?
Whoopsies.
He's a skinwalker.
Honestly, at least it's with us.
Sorry.
I can't...
I actually have to play with the flashlight off
to see them better than with the on.
I mean, I don't even mind.
Hi, Rizzo.
Can you guys still see those?
I can... No, I think he's...
They lost their textures.
Dead and lost his texture?
That's even worse.
Okay, I'll help you move it.
Oh, sorry, I'm on the floor.
Yeah, we can still see.
As long as you can see them.
I guess that's all but marry.
I was gonna say, damn, he took a shot in the hip.
I mean, he took a shot in the hip.
Rather efficient, Rizzo.
Very good technique.
Yes, yes, 10 out of 10.
Did he take a different path?
I see you.
Sorry, this is like a horror game right now.
I'm reloading after every shot so I can spam
in case I muck up.
I wonder if they can't see me either in the tunnel.
I remember seeing an account
of tunnel warfare.
Oh, I shot off his leg perfectly.
That's really gross.
That ain't the most dying solid team.
Hello, daddy's home.
I can't stand up now.
The pysons are bad.
Gasp, gasp, gasp.
Quick, grab the documents.
Can we grab the documents?
Aren't we supposed to grab the documents?
I'm crawling as a main chef.
Crawly, crawly, crawl.
Come on.
Press V.
I'm digging a hole.
I'm digging out the hole.
We made it, we made it.
No, no, no, I don't like that.
Oh my god, that activated the actual thing in me.
I get tunnel vision when I play games.
I'm not kidding.
Oh thank god.
Bring us close.
I was like so well done.
Did the shadow people try to kill you in Vietnam, Mason?
I don't know what section in the campaign we're in,
but I feel like we're kind of getting there.
I don't know how many levels.
I know there's one level and it goes,
we're on a boat and it goes down,
down, down.
Listen to me carefully, Mason.
Hydrogation check.
I've almost finished my bottle of water.
I'm so hydrated.
No matter what he tells you.
He gave us the Darcy Ion Clark.
He let us to Nova 6.
If you thought that was time.
He's my friend.
He helped me escape.
Are you squiddin' me right now?
Time to head back to work.
But I hope you enjoy it.
Thanks for spending your break with me.
Thank you.
Who the fuck are you anyway?
Make sure you hydrate at work.
Make sure you rest after work.
And make sure you prepare for your 30 minute
decompressed job after work.
When you get home.
I've been brainwashed.
I don't know the numbers mean something.
Wow.
Oh, this is literally the mission I was thinking of.
They're the next lottery numbers.
Okay.
This is literally the mission I was talking about.
Are you ready for some music?
As they start to realize.
Realize.
Okay.
Enough with the white backgrounds.
I can hardly see them.
I'm like looking in my eyes.
Oh, I hear the numbers.
They're becoming a lot more prevalent.
Mason in 1968.
Did you know the men landing
was 1969?
Wait, is this not the mission?
Could've sworn it was.
Hello everyone.
Hello, good job soldiers.
Well done.
Well done, soldiers.
Resnovas with us.
But notice how no one interacts
with Resnovas.
A pinup.
Well, if you're in the need for a pinup.
Yes, but Azura got a pinup.
Mousepad design.
If you're in the business for a mousepad.
Use WASD to move and mouse to look
and aim.
Oh, it's rather
not insanely responsive.
I'll allow it.
We have to drive and fire.
Are you ready?
I don't know this song that well.
That was different.
I'm just smiling.
I'm smiling.
Hold on, I must go back.
What was that?
Song is sympathy for the devil.
Oh, really?
Jeez.
I'm sorry, I just got annihilated by something.
That wasn't me.
You can't prove it.
That genuinely wasn't me.
I don't know why they have
friendly fire on.
That wasn't my fault.
They were killed in action.
That's technically not wrong.
They did get killed in action.
I can't.
Can I break the bridge?
I'm trying.
I may die on an ironic level, but can I
see?
ship on fire can someone like splash some water on the hull that would be
great now I'm no one want to put some water on the hull I can see thank you
the story we're in the river I'm freaking burning up okay we killed off we
killed all me and the boys how much freaking ammo you take fire again
oh no the front guy perished something shouldn't behind us as long as it's
having a good time ramming speed literally that's the best I could do
ram I swear to God the woods was crying but he never let us see no tears nothing
so far wait something's in the trees never happened here we just missed their
trees we're gonna die in this one there's nothing here that was our boss
battle as Ramam I'm like sorry I don't have any time to shoot and spray
so
I
Feel
Say again
Drift Chanko, we must be near fucking hope so
Whoa confirmation ground zero
Beep beep beep
Everyone let me rotate is it like oh i'm on a disneyland park right it's moving on its own now
They don't trust me a park. Jeez. So you trust me to drive the thing, but you don't trust me a park
On that disneyworld experience
Speaking of disneyland. Whoa, what happened?
What's the news i don't i don't listen to like i don't have time to even consume the news if i'm honest
Did something happen
Splash man has a lot more
Explosions than i remember it really
You can't spawn in front of me. That's the spawn render distance. That's not it
You're supposed to obey the rules of the spawn render
Now
The biggest women moment these are just so far i can't believe it
Where
Can you elik if you
I promise you if i ever make a video game that has allies they will actually shoot and kill
This is redonkulous
Not to be confused with
Where who's sniping in the tree? Oh
That's creative
Oh, i must have like a safety vest to keep him in the tree
Oh, well we're under we're under fire under fire
Tangles tangles to get down get down
Oh, that's the smart with a little lightbulb
To show that he's sniping from there me where what tree there's so many around us
If you guys can see him in the tree, why don't you shoot him instead of doing a call it up?
He's in the tree controversial
No
Could you imagine doing warfare and oh you hear the enemy goes
All your allies go down one by one
So they'll freaking that's my internal
My external dialogue
I like have a tannoy just to wind them up
Um, and i'm like allowed to speak on the tannoy. It's like a massacre
Hello guys, don't be afraid. It's your device. Just me
Very unprofessional, I feel like maybe it would take you so off course
Would it make you on would you make it on nerven because like I know war tactics. They play like drone sounds or like
um
Like droning music sometimes
A good thing i'm only 123 pounds, please don't fall off mason and your fellow
Please don't fall off. Where am I supposed to go? I sit down here. I'm gonna go down here
I'm going to go into the fuselage to find out what I need
What's inside the box, I guess I need the
Yeah, I was gonna say I think I need one of them to help me
Imagine if death makes for a thing in real life. There's a blast heavy metal from minor
Mocking the enemy always slower than
This guy's enjoying the killing
So Disney finally backed down. Oh, that's I ever call
Yeah, if you didn't hear the news about Disney
A man's waist passed the way due to severe allergy
at the restaurant
And disney cleaned that because he signed up for disney plus and because of their fishy terms and conditions that aren't realistic
um
That he's not allowed to do them for mal
Practice or whatever it's called
and
Because they said like hey, no allergy that's fine and then served her and she like literally perished
Um, but they dropped it
So I don't think it's going to court anymore
But everyone's like no it should go to court because this should set a president
That terms and conditions are absolutely I have a sniper that terms and conditions are just like absolute nonsense
and shouldn't
be ever like abused like that
Um
But I think because they because disney gave up and you want to know the worst part
You know the settlement
The guy wasn't even asking for much like, you know how
when you like
Get compensation for loss of life for that. It's not like he was one. I want
17 billion dollars. No, he literally
Um asked for like a super reasonable amount to continue his life without his loved one
I mean, of course he's going to take time off working and have loss of income and all this jazz
like
The money isn't to compensate for like the actual literal death
It's to compensate for the loss of quality of his life
and he could have obviously have um
Asked for a lot more and he was like no, I just
This is apparently how much I need to live and that's what I'm going to ask for
Um, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, put it down mason mason. You're not a boy
Oh, wait. No, these are the baddies. I take it back mason shoot
They found
We must make up for lost time. No, no, no, no, no ow
Naughty
You never get off the boat
Off the boat get off the boat baby
What does disney plus have to do with a restaurant basically they had like a
clause thing and signing up for disney plus
that or
A you can't sue us or something and everyone was like, huh?
And once it made the news obviously disney got bad press for it
So they dropped it but it was only because it made the news if it didn't make the news
Uh, it wouldn't have been dropped
They would have taken it to court, which is absolutely discussed
I want mommy's film me just like that. Hear me. I want to pass it
Oh, I'm not ordered the artwork yet for oh, I'm silly. Oh my god
I can I can contact the artist to make that scene from uh, the honey happy sugar life
And then I'm going to do a little dodging strip and I'm going to be black
I'm very happy finding that artist. I got very lucky finding her. She's a dream to work with
um
She did a zurra's mouse pad
And I like basically blew into her messages. I was like
Hi, um, are you willing to work with feeler?
We have a few things that we'd like to do with you and she's like, oh, we got share
What do you want? And I'm like, um, um, I know these things but unfortunately the deadline's super quick and she's oh, that's fine
I'm like, oh my god. I love you
Maybe we should like
exchange goods and services for money with each other
Oh, isn't sr 71
For gen 4 confirmed
Are you ready? So this is a black bird
I remember this mission. It's like birds. I be an embodiment
mommy blacks million due into
Whipping it out for her to see how you self carry some more
I'll write that I'll write that
Um, who's idea was it to give us or a toggle to take our horns and ears off because it was genius. Um
Uh
She did it. You can take the vtuber model and like hide stuff. Like, you know how I did the 10k subscriber milestone stream
I had to take my toggle clothes off for that. Like
Uh, you can go into the layers in vtuber studio and hide and remove stuff
That's how she was able to do that human version because she went into our model and like hide them and made it a toggle
We're getting indicated to find kilo one. I'm attacking. Yeah, like when we get it all. Yeah
So it wasn't like a toggle that like was purchased or anything. Oh my god. I'm so sorry. Right. I need to focus up
I've got I've got tangles
Affirmative I got him kilo one. This is big eye six. I have you on the trp
Okay, kilo you need to move east
Press space
Okay, I press space
Okay, they're moving
Get into the
Yes, yes, yes
Okay, safe house. Good. Good. Good. No tangles inside. You guys just see passing by the house
Wait, no enemy has stopped in front of the house. Oh
I'm oh, this is okay. This is such a cool mission. This may be one of the best missions. I don't know
I don't know call me bias. This is a pretty cool mission
Would it be my favorite?
Oh
This things are diabolical
Okay, I think we're okay
Kilo you are clear
Okay, the road is hot exit through the rear of the building
Go
Okay, so first exit through the building and then beat him up
Two target sighted kill him
Oh
Good nice work kilo one now you can make it over here safely
Flashbangs really do be flushed. I can't believe the sole purpose of a flashbang is the flash and it's working
The objective is inside
Kilo stop and drop
Confirm kilo one you're out of sight
Oof
I think you're gonna discover that building
We're gonna discover something wrong with that building you guys don't need to get a move on
All clear kilo one
Okay, attack the barracks multiple targets inside reaching clear kilo one. Oh, they're gonna know
They're gonna know
A story of the calls what is thy wisdom?
Famous that's my wisdom. Famous is the best gun in black ops one
The recoil is really fair
And the hip fire is really fair and it's such a good gun. That's my wisdom to do
It's the best gun ever and if you have joe mac the reload time is really good
That's my words of wisdom and I will not argue otherwise
Everyone must agree that this is the best gun in this game
Famous I see such good wisdom. Thank you. Thank you
Kilo move north move north. Okay space bar
Space bar
On our way over
Kilo one we have infantry inbound
Accountably six targets too hot stop and drop stay out of sight
They really made me do a cutscene for that gave the squad to the Soviet oposite again
Huh
No, my game did you crash?
Hmm
I act as like it crashed there
He was still talking to me in the cutscene and I never cooked anything
What about the galeo?
I'll give you the galeo galeo surprise was actually really good as well for the extra ammunition at 35 in the chamber in the mag
Everyone went and their mother used the famine it just was a well-rounded gun
I'm so juicy
Well, this is rather terrifying
I ain't touching the thing
We are quite the teamer for that freaking invisible, honestly
I
Almost messed up because I was going to run to the door like hi. I could completely be spawns
Sneaky time the galeo or is that called the galeo?
Big guy this is galeo one. We still have some tech. I live in
Famous visibility has improved. We're starting out in search of moving to the substation
Big eyes for combat centering the structure over. Roger that big guy. We're going in
I hate this mission because of the dogs. Yeah, unfortunately, but a dog. Go to the but
Ready
Steady
Right to raffle
Left to break right to raffle
to break
raffle
break
Break
I break
I think I promise I clicked it. I promise I did
Let's go. Oh, you need to hold it. Oh
I didn't realize how dangerous uh descending was
Okay, there we go. Oh, we did it
Okay, I'm dumb. Okay. Oh, no, we need another sequence again. Oh no
Dead's 18. There's no way I've died 18 times. You would think I've never played this game before
Ready when you are
He's right mouse
Wrong one. I was left or right, honestly
I can't see
Uh
Oh, sorry. Oh, sorry weaver my bad and my defense you're in front of my bullet
As much as I want to find this it's not silent. Where does this make sense for the stealth mission?
so I'ma be it and behave and
I'ma behave and listen to the game
The r word stands for repel exactly the one over six thunder gun section was a lot. No
No, wait, I got it first time. I knew exactly I already knew about that Easter egg and I did not learn about it today
Why is Hudson getting cool emissions than mason? I think mason's like wrap up and look at the end though
Okay, gently tip-tap tip-tap tip-tap tip-tap. We're tipping tapping down the hill
With the tip-tap in case the game's gonna tell us to drop and roll one a minute
Wow, I'm ready. I'm ready. Come on. Come on. Bring it to me
Kilo one approaching the objective
That big guy we're going in
Okay, after this one we get a drink and stretch and get some food seeds
Can you do this killing them both?
Oh
Okay, they're actually helping me a Christmas miracle. Oh, I did it correct
Why would I
Oh
Well, I tried I thought I did really well
Didn't quite because they were helping me kill like the other person that came with them, you know
Ow
I think I have to walk through to this part
There's a door here, but
Oh
Maybe
This no candy beef. Oh is I was like
Damage drop off maybe go loud. Oh shit. Sorry. Sorry. I'm talking to the reef lens. Okay, geez
I can't move over the
In coded when they have coded things like this you can't go around them. They're like blocking the air
Let me in
Uh, who am I shooting not the scientists?
There was one over there
Sorry, I shouldn't have fired
Don't kill the scientists. They're just trying to forget pretty sick. Yeah, they're doing diabolical things against humanity
Or manufacturing the diabolical things, but
I don't know. Maybe maybe we should look into some scientists. I wouldn't be down for that. I would be
Sorry, I'm getting a blurt rate. Hold on
I'm getting a blurt rate. Hold on. Let me be a fish. I'm just a busy. I'm just a busy on the floor
Oh
Oh, what how are they coming in we came from there
We literally came from above
Move weaver
Please sorry. I lost my temperature. I apologize. Please may we progress to the next mission objective?
So I can make a cup of tea. Thank you. I would like to make a cup of tea
And I would like I certainly was gonna disable are you joking? You should rip it out the whole thing
It's gonna take them so long to replace those wires. I'm sure they don't have replacements at all
Where
What RPG where all right then geez
Who's my little mass murderer?
Pick me pick me
I can't see anything
Although I need to lock in gamers. I cannot see I am slipping and I think I'm about to slide off the edge of the avalanche
POV uh
You're my parents going to school you what do you mean? He's right there
Was I to jump?
We're clear
I'm not being teased
Was that to jump off of that?
Don't say 19. Damn it
I I looked over and instantly saw it
You to jump right I'll jump I didn't realize they had parishes
Oh, so he's coded
Wow
Okay, let me try again
I'm running I'm running I'm running I'm running
I'm jumping off the uh
If you if your comrades would jump off a cliff would you yeah, yeah, I would I'm gonna do it right now
You ready ready to see this in 4k?
No, are you ready to see this in 1080p?
Okay, three two one
I'm getting frostbite
Do you want to maybe go forward a bit so we don't hit the cliff edge press F
We're in an enemy calm. Ow my ankles. That was a very fast descent. Okay. Is that the cliff I jumped on? Maybe
Are we quiet yet or is it quiet time or
I mean they look pretty ready for a fight. I'm gonna be honest. Yeah, I think I don't think it needs to be quiet here
I guess they probably would have heard the explosions on top of the hill, you know, maybe maybe the loud explosion
Yeah, I might have tipped them off that there's something going on in the compound. That isn't quite right. Hmm
Our radio. Yeah radio was pretty big back then so communication
Yeah, now that now they're taking to consideration
Yes, that was rather rather small brained of me don't mind me though. I love the small
Mg machine gun. Oh, I can't even see it
Give me in that building
Give me in the building right what we're doing in here. We're hip firing
Honestly, I must say all the maps feel really different from each other as well like even though they're oh, sorry weaver you're in my way
I'd say sorry, but it's your problem
You got your problem if you walk in front of my billets every two things
You see these wires
Yeah, this place is rigged to blow
Rigged to blow
Make it fast. There's not much time
What do you mean analyzing? Yes. One two three four five six seven eight nine ten eleven twelve twelve nuke points of nuba six
Okay, understood. They've picked. Oh, that's florida
Okay, that's florida
Alabama's make the florida that's Texas
That's california
That's Alaska up there. That's kind of calorado don't weave it
That's north canada rellena
That's seattle. I think
What are you?
I'm just gonna say you're mississippi, but I don't know what you are
I tried
no seattle
carolina
Wait am i dying
Sorry don't have time for a gunfight stop stop brah
Brah, I ain't even bro. Give me cover. Give me cover. I'm literally didn't even get out of the damn cutscene thing
I'm already like about to perish. Please
Please jeez
What the heck am I supposed to run past them? I don't know that seems silly. I feel like they're gonna get me
Stop
Brah
Thank you
Am I to get on that? I think I'm to get on this truck get on the truck guys
Come on gang. Come on gang
Oh, no, that did count against my time
Uh, I really hope I still have enough time to get out of here
Oh, no the timer's gone the timer's gone. It's fine. We're okay. We're safe
Is the time now the ease how you say
Fini
Is it? Oh, wait. Oh, there is an avalanche
Okay, thank you
We're safe. Famous. I know it's her geography. Wait, did I just do it? I think Alaska was a bit higher up. Oh
Maybe we should name the state
Now they're ready to strike
If all the people I trust are running and jumping off the bridge, I'm gonna trust soon
Get it to him to call us enough. Thank you. That's right. I'm going to emigrate to the united states of america
Stop
Where is the broadcast station?
This is like rats in cages
We are all brothers. We are all praesters
We're going back to my delusion we're out alone
Mason
Mason you with me?
Is this actually how they used to torture these like let you sit in cold water and barbwire
Hey, mama, I'm glad to catch your stream today. I missed it yesterday, but I enjoyed watching the vod
I hope you're having fun playing black ops. I am we're doing really well with the campaign
Thank you, husband. I'm glad you enjoy the vods
I always worry that the vods aren't enjoyable like cuz it's like oh, I'm not there, but I really enjoyed tavern master
It's more gruesome or they'd stick bamboo in between you
What the fuck
Shit
Holy fuck
Fuckers
I'm gonna make them pay you. No talk play
What's the pain I'm thinking I'm thinking no talk. Why don't you hate me? No take it. Okay
You can't kill me
You shoot gi you shoot
Fuck
Oh my god
Oh, okay
Play yes, yes, I'll play leave it this bill in your brain mass
Oh
Close enough through your heart mass I'll take it
Give me that gun. Give me the gun turn around probably by turn around. Give me a twirl
Okay, bonk boom, but it being camp pow. Okay. I'm okay. I did it. I did it
Can you lose it this far? I think if you're not reactive enough. Yeah
Oh, hold on a minute. I can't believe it when you go to Vietnam. There's Vietnamese people. It's shocking
I've got his knees
Okay, sorry
I've pardoned my speed, but I was tickling me
I
Got machete. I like how you paused to let me kill him. That was really a polite of you
Let's bless you what happened. I'm like really tickly sneezes that make me go like
But then sometimes I scare it away when I do that
So I still got the relief of sneezing. Shoot him. Fuck you, bitch
You got him
Let's go when you got time to waste
I wasn't supposed to that just startled me. Did I scare you? I'm coming again
I can't be far. People pass these days on number
Oh the flowers we have blue lily gorgeous. Oh
You see that hines? Yeah, we're gonna take it. You're gonna drive though, right?
Okay
One two three four five six seven eight. Okay
Easy we don't want to damage the the ride, you know
So let's not do any accidental cross bullets fire on the rides. Let's get close and personal. How are we?
There we go
Please don't make me fly it. I think you're gonna make me fly it
Oh
I don't remember getting my license. I don't have a license for this flying the bird is part of the fun
But I can't fly
Ready
I don't think this soldier has ever had flying training before
Oh, wait, he's doing it. Oh, like I think he's doing it. I think I think we're safe
Got it. Give me the stick
No, don't give me the stick. Take it back. Take the stick back. You're the man. Okay
No, I'm evasive maneuver
Oh my goodness
Oh
I don't know if I'm doing that right. I don't know if I should keep going or
Put him out of business facing
Come on
Okay, there we go
How am I constant?
Give me my
Wait for the reload it's taking forever and I've had terrible aim
I'm getting shredded out here. You need to this machine needs to reload. Oh my god. I'm gonna like crash into our rock
I'm not even gonna die because of the enemy. It's literally my driving like why are we like tilted
Like why are we tilting?
I don't know even though this is gonna like I think I'm spraying
I'm spraying
Good job
Is that enough bridge destruction? Yeah. Yeah, that's right. That's why it's a big convoy. Yeah. Yeah, I'm not sure I get right
Mommy I'm gonna be sick. Oh, no, I never even thought about the motion sickness. I'm so sorry. Please close your eyes, Brooklyn
I'm gonna make you so sick
Is that it?
Can I go higher up? I don't know. I feel like it'd be a bit safer mason to go a bit higher
I don't know. What do you think?
What do you think son?
Do you think we should be higher up in the fucking stratosphere?
Instead of two feet off the ground, I can harvest the freaking race crops from here. They're right below me
Go up. Why are we so scared of going a bit higher?
Come on
Um
I see um, but you need to reload a bit faster. I don't know. I'm spraying but nothing's happening. Okay, that one exploded
I just can't eat thank you. Jeez right and we're destroying the homes as well. Sorry, but
I
Must be another bridge
That's what I think about your infrastructure as well. Yep destroy the infrastructure
Wait, why did I hear random rushing in the background? Is that supposed to be?
Or
Is the way oh, is it from Russian military or something like all the assets?
I think I've just backed up on the hill. Uh, I'm on fire not to be dramatic or anything, but I am on fire
It's no letting it
Oh, thank goodness. I finished that sequence you took their chopper
Because you're in one of their birds good thing we survived it's a bit rough, but a few sparks here and there never killed anyone
Checkpoint
Are we good?
Yeah, okay. All good. Yeah, we did it
Gambati whoops gambati needs him
Well something tells me we're gonna have a lot of enemies right i'ma keep my a key. I like my reason to play this quiet mason
There's only two of us. Are you sure?
Well he's going for it. Oh, wow. You actually killed someone a christmas miracle
Unless you recorded and then I will take back my compliment
Are we gonna I wonder if there's any war stories when like the odds really were like against them
Did someone hit me from up there?
Oh an RPG or something stop it
You're turning me on
No, you're not sorry
I'm away
Excuse me
This was before the Geneva convention was made, right?
Hold on hold on try figure out
Oh
He patted himself off
All right, let me just pat myself off. You're on a boot
1949 no scope. Who are you shooting at?
Is there someone here?
Who's out there? Hey
Please
You're here for us. Get you out. Fuck. Thank god. Please. Hurry. Oh the button. You mean the big button on the roadside?
Oh
Oh my god, they had the poop in our bucket. What kind of torture is this?
We're in charge of your own destiny now and you mean
Your punishment is to smell your stinky poopy
Oh, hold on wait war crimes time. Oh after the grenade after the grenade pop. Ow. How did I?
Hold on war crime time. No
Oh, I'm on fire too. Sorry. I'm on fire too. Hold on. Let me reload
Oh
Okay, I should maybe wear a suit when I do this. Yeah, I think I need a suit for this kind of thing
I'm trying
I'm trying but I need a suit. I need a fire suit
From my own crime
Knock knock. Hello
Time to die. Oh
Ow
Beat him up. That's right. Fuck him up. Fuck him up. Oh, no, wait. Oh, no
Not this time American. No, how did we're so close
You are gay
Yes
That's a nice son of a bitch you die
Oh my god, what a nightmare
Woman and what?
You're okay
Are you okay?
No, I don't think so. I don't think Mason's doing so good
Look at the symbolism on that picture
Really message to CIA station
None of us are okay
No, you can't convince me
Resmond is in there
No, I wasn't rogue. I was continuing the mission
You went to rebirth island and death's orders. Why Mason?
Steiner was there. We had to kill Steiner and Wilson and the CIA. We're already on their way to get Steiner and Revers
Why did you have to go to Agovitch Kravchenko Steiner? They all had to die
Steiner alive. Why did you have to kill it? The numbers were telling me too. Why don't you fucking understand?
Yeah
Brain worms
Oh
I like the idea that they're interrogating me and then they keep passing out and I go
And they're like, oh, we need the numbers. What are you doing?
Okay, this one I always mess up. I think this one's so hard
I always this has a
Ah reef fling me on my deathbed
Ah reef fling
They always say I suck at this one. I always mess up. Oh my god, the stream re-owned
Does it mean she's bored? No, it means she's welcoming me
There's nothing here
You do have to tell me twice
What had to oh the one on him, okay checkpoint reached I'll take it
So we need to be quiet
I cuddled his mummy in bed you wait until I get a plushie of you and it's gonna be over
I'ma hump you and my arm would you and my tingle you? Oh, I need to stay out of the helicopter spotlight
Okay
Okay steady wait until resnob moves when resnob moves we can move
Here
I just follow him because
Maybe I can do it correctly for the first time
Who knows
Easy
Let's go get him
Halt you're screaming
Okay
Stay where you are
I'm not going anywhere. I'm just looking around. I guess this way
Oh my god, have I done it for the first time without messing up?
Peepies peeping mummies and shivers down a spine
The only one I socialize but she says it's real time
No
Sorry, I I was too busy
I was too busy singing the world's most inappropriate song
And I got scared. Oh, maybe that's the noise I make when I come at you
I
Claim me claim me claim me
Yes, look at them back
Okay, are you ready? Okay you first
Okay
They'll they'll let oh we're going down the lift
I sure hope someone doesn't go inside it
Other than other force
I won't fit right the Soviet lab and confronts them
What is that
Ah, I might take the aq for something. I'm not killing
So this is where zombies started. They made it like it was like the supernova
It's sorry not the supernova
Nova six is like why the monkey zombies happen like they've already got hints of it on the wall and that
Excuse me. I'm trying to say the lore of college a stop shooting me, please
Stop shooting me
Okay, the hip fire isn't so good in this one
Thanks girl for gin
Not the scientists
Gosh, that's a lot of enemies. I don't know how good my armor is but it is like insane. I have like fantastic armor
For it to be having a carry on like
Ow
There's no I know you're not here right now, but I need you to be a wee bit more here
A lot more than
Oh, that's rough. What are you you're inside it
You
Yeah, let's go upstairs. Nope. No, we're not. Oh, yep. Here we are. Okay. I need them to open the door first
Please come and open the door, please come. Yes. Okay, close door goods
Let us
Men are rounding up everyone on the island. Hi Stainer long time no see buddy
I'm being executed. You must hurry before they kill me too
Oh
Yeah
I
I have Strony Culls and I will have my revenge!
Rrraah! Rrraah!
Rrraah!
Brrraah!
Hi, Strony and Chat, I'm here!
20 minutes earlier on the south side.
Strony Wick.
Wait, Miss Strony, when did you get a gun?
I always had one.
I see straps, like CD.
In that one short.
Inking squad, we're moving!
Top squad, let's roll!
Copy that, we're on the move!
Okay, so while Mason's sneaking around,
we are in massive ass tanks,
alert in the whole neighborhood to our tank clap.
I like the contrast, I like the contrast of like,
still, still, still.
And then these two are like, Rrraah!
Big tank, big tank.
Big tanku desu.
Oh, they got the water power.
That's like an Olympic thing, like you're late on fire.
Oh, that's the enemy.
Sorry, I thought I maybe had bombs or something,
but I was like, nope, just zooming in and out.
Just casually zooming in and out, sorry.
Where are we going?
We're going a little to the right.
Okay, I'll take the right.
This tank has a lot of overheat though.
It's happening very quickly.
How does the car blown up next to you not kill you?
But when a car blows up like eight feet away from me,
eight feet, no, eight miles away from me,
the game's like, nice try.
You want to go in your try again?
Nerd.
My tank is on fire.
I'm just going to pretend it's shrapnel
that's on fire at the front of the tank,
but I think I may actually lose
and my gun is overheating.
The panther definitely is overheating.
Yeah, yeah, that's it.
It's not on fire, it's overheating.
Yeah, there's a difference.
Yeah, yeah, there's a difference.
What, this?
Oh, did that die?
No, that was scripted.
Okay, good.
They're in novices.
Oh, we're in novices.
Oh, no.
He didn't make it.
He had like a crack.
Oh!
Okay, right.
This, curious, interesting.
Oh my God, it's like, oh,
they're literally cannot see through the thickness.
I can, like, hardly see a thing.
I can see a thing.
I don't ever remember using this site in multiplayer.
I feel like it's too awkward,
like, just open your eyes to see the enemy.
I said something,
I shouldn't have made fun over there, but...
Any intel?
No intel.
I feel like whenever they design something
that you can kind of, like, do a U-turn on,
that's where they're secretly putting the intel.
Right, I guess my suit doesn't heal
and it'll crack until I'm dead,
so I'm, yeah, ooh, yeah, yeah, that, that!
That's what I don't want,
so I'm gonna try and play a bit safer than usual.
Uh-huh.
That was...
What are you, a civilian?
Oh my gosh, I'm trying to play careful,
but somehow I'm actually playing worse
to try to be careful
than I am if I was just guns-ablezin'.
Okay, I need to out of this section,
like, ace up, how about that?
Can we go upstairs in the fire?
As if I wouldn't melt the suit.
The suit's not, like, invincible.
As much as I have a temperature to, you know...
Okay, can I make it across?
Let me, at least.
I'm trying to be...
I'm so dainty, I'm such a skinny soldier.
I'm so skinny that you can't shoot me
and you don't know where I am.
I blend in with the walls.
Okay.
Ow, ow, ow, ow!
There's a frickin' Huey!
How am I supposed to go against the Huey?
Where is it?
Oh, there is.
Hold on.
Gimme, gimme, gimme, gimme.
Gimme.
That...
One more? That wasn't it?
Hold on, let me refire inside this house.
Are you joking?
I think I'm about to perish.
Okay.
I don't, I'm getting nervous.
I'm getting nervous.
I've lost my little gun as well.
Drap.
Hopefully it's a bit clearer.
This thing's about to crack.
It looks like cobble wobbles on my screen.
Okay.
I'm allowed a regular gun now, so...
Make it through Novo without dying.
I've got a mini achievement for that.
Thank you.
I feel so accomplished.
I'm so...
Ow!
So, we're not doing this RPG shit already.
Leave me alone.
My biggest enemy, RPG.
Oh, that's an enemy?
His gun was so low down, I thought he was the head.
No, don't throw nades at me.
Only ammo to do it.
But we're getting there.
I actually think we're about to finish.
I was gonna go get like tea and water and food and that,
but I'm like, honestly...
I...
My...
If we're about to kill the second guy...
Doesn't that mean we're literally around the corner from finishing
and cracking the case with Mason's numbers?
Um...
Because, yeah...
We can have a little yap after.
Hold on.
Oh, do not blow this car up.
Don't make myself clear.
Don't be selfish.
Um...
I think you should get some water.
I'm gonna see if I have the energy to make my...
I'm gonna focus on my...
Patreon audio.
I don't know...
If I should try and stay up and get big boy sleep,
or...
If I should...
Sorry, I have a really itchy thumb.
Gimli clawed me earlier.
I swear if I got infected, I'm right down.
Oh!
Oh, did that nade feel nice, yeah?
He just ate that fucking nade.
And I did get me wrong.
I love a good architect moment, but eating a nade,
that's where I draw the line.
Yeah, you're crossing stuff.
That shouldn't be happening.
Oh, let's hack into the mainframe.
People, people, people.
Wiggly, wiggly water.
Get rested.
What, and then...
Get rested, get rested, get rested.
Nap, nap, nap, nap, nap.
True.
Here.
Okay, we're decontaminated.
Oh, we're trying to talk to Mason from this POV.
Oh no.
I think it's too late.
I don't know, something tells me to leave it too late for Mason.
Someone called at a pineapple moment,
someone got hungry and ate an onion refill
and you fell for peppers.
Oh, we're frying them up.
Make a Simon just super too much right now.
I'll be very interested to see how it turns out.
I'm really excited to use lentils.
I know, I know, I've been talking about it for days now.
But look, I just get excited, okay?
So he's already killed everything in the lab.
Almost everything.
Yeah, it's like just straight up a trial.
Oh, wait, hold on.
There is a few left behind, but yeah, this makes sense.
Mason cleared it out.
He was on the phone to us?
This door?
I don't like I died with them.
Beep boop beep boop, are you gonna let me in?
I have to open the door, okay.
We're on the wrong side of the...
Oh my gosh, yes, I remember.
Oh.
Mason, no.
Let it go.
Stop it, go to sleep.
Go to sleep.
Yeah, there's none to check there.
There is absolutely none to check.
He's sleeping.
Wow.
I was gonna say, someone gonna pick Mason up.
Now we're just gonna watch him pass out.
Oh right, okay, no.
Wait, so why did he randomly fire there?
Is there an enemy in this one?
That's what I'm saying, what did he shoot?
He just wanted to be like, okay, Steiner's definitely dead.
Maybe he's reasonable along.
They must be stopped, Mason.
Yeah, well, we only got like two more to go?
That I felt like better on Resnord TV.
Damn.
Did that mean he's dressed in press rub off on you?
He was in for a coup d'etat, he knows how to translate.
He got strewn and snapped on the kids game.
Yeah, two more missions.
Yeah, okay, let's just lock in.
Seriously, I would take a break in that if there was long ahead,
but we're really nailing it.
Okay, I finished my bowling, voil.
He's so dramatic.
Hi, Hudson.
I thought it was going to be a friendly reunion.
I've been brainwashed.
Yeah.
Rim Nain.
Alex Mason.
What are they saying?
I'd push myself on that.
We're spiraling.
The average refling when Momay isn't streaming.
Where's Bubba?
I can hear her voice, her accent.
Oh, it's good, slow-mo.
It's good, slow-mo.
Is that for Mason to go even more?
Oh, I was just holding there.
Oh.
He's unusual.
Atypical.
Few men possess such will.
Our other test subjects have been far more successful.
Why not use them?
If he was not only one of those intelligent adults,
then he is of no use to me.
Aw.
Take him back to his cell.
Oh, my God.
What do you want to say?
That's all I want you to say.
Oh, my God.
This is the target.
Huh?
Oh, my God.
Oh.
Open the door.
That's a slimy zone.
Oh.
He is crumbling, like, paper.
You want me on Sunday feeling?
Oh, sorry.
Why on Sunday would I be like that?
Wait, what does that mean?
Thank you, boy.
What happened on Monday?
Oh.
Oh, Hudson Gauze.
That slimy zone was just me and Ken.
Don't worry about it.
Reznor came to brainwash me.
Who else is there?
He was never there.
No, he wasn't there because I couldn't see him.
One man, Mason army.
It's like the game got really quiet all of a sudden.
Oh, my God.
One man was there.
He wanted revenge for all the Dragovich stuff.
Dragovich, Krakchenko, Steiner, three new victims.
There are gaps in your memory.
Periods where you went MIA and we couldn't account for you.
But now that the brainwashing's been broken,
all that lost time will come back.
We need to leave.
The Nova 6 strike is imminent.
Hundreds of sleeper agents hidden in every state capital
are about to unleash this poison on your own countrymen.
When Steiner died, we lost our key
to unlocking the location of Numbagrodna.
You were programmed to conclude to translate the number code.
Only you can tell us what the codes mean.
Nova 6 was just one of the sleeper operations.
But I'm sure there were others, ones we didn't even know about.
We have the broadcast.
We played them to you over and over again for hours,
but we haven't been able to break through your programming yet.
Mason, this is our last shot.
Listen, for God's sake, listen again.
21, 7, 21, 4, 2, 14, 3, 14, 7, 18, 13, 6.
Do what you wish, General.
This might give to you an honourable relationship.
You don't know what we did to you.
The subject has been successfully implanted
with the knowledge to translate the number sequences.
Plan to strike at the very heart of the West is now in motion.
Await further instructions.
We know.
Do what you wish, General.
This might give to you an honourable relationship.
An honourable relationship.
Permanent broadcast station within their portals.
All these questions will be broadcast from the radio station.
Would the numbers mean?
It's a ship.
I saw it a long time ago.
The Rosalga.
Where?
Cuba.
I hit it!
Not the guitar riff in sunglasses.
Oh my God, that was funny.
Sorry.
I probably would have had a laugh and fit over that if I wasn't tired.
I'm not even gonna lie.
Do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do.
Sunglasses.
Wait, they put Mason back in the fight?
That was badass.
Aw yeah, guitar riff.
I'm here to kick ass and chew bubblegum
It's time to fuck ass and chew gum I'm all over what
Wait, is that a different what wait you both said the same meme
This I mean, I don't know about I'm out in the means here
Alpha we got
Golf of Mexico
Viva la Mexico, hola come as a
Hola
So I can drive sorry, I didn't realize I was driving
Sorry about that old chap that was me didn't realize I could drive this. That's a rather embarrassing
Do excuse me. Let me go around the outside around the outside of the bow of the boat
Something's getting me. Oh dear. Oh dear. I'm being a I'm being wrecked as the young and sending wrecked
One more
We secured the landing zone protect and attack. No protect. Okay. Just protect got it. I
Mean I'm spamming
I'm spamming I
Keep overheating though. I think that's a me problem with the way I play this game
Bruh, there's no way you would even dare to exit if there's three Huey's above spamming. I
Shant I shan't believe it. I shan't believe such risk-taking
I'm trying to hit him I'm doing a terrible job
What do you mean get you closer
Am I didn't cover fire for a ground unit that way
Okay, did we do it? I think we did it. We're doing it. We're on Rosalga
Wow, I can't believe they actually tagged me in though
Like I'm not being funny if you were found to be an agent and like doing all this stuff
They would null you back on the team, right?
I
Stop moving stop resisting
The thing went in my way well, hopefully it saved all that progress
Right do you you're the baddie know that the freaking ally choppers and like right in my face I
Know
Are you doing it again go away?
If you're just gonna be a detriment get out of my face my frickin teammate
Am I just a Ramam I'm just rhyming them. Sorry
No, you're getting rammed. Sorry
No, get fucked. How are you not dead?
Please be so for real right now get out of my way. I
Am
Hamming no was gonna see
Right
What was that something like a fart meow can you back up to the helipad?
Oh
Okay, so I was supposed to happen
Please don't let me fall I don't want to go down. Thank you
How are you Hudson you feeling all right had better you need a little coffee you feel better
Oh
Now all I'm gonna see is that we have caused a heck of a lot of destruction
I can't imagine how many men were
Manned on the ship, but I feel like we've already decimated a lot of their numbers. It may be controversial, but I
Feel like they should oh have two
Editions on this one. I have a red dot say and Joe what's mag which means my reed old times is super fast
I
I'm trying to get that red barrel to blow up
That's shit
Wow, I'm not touching it
Valkyrie rockets my tame has come what one this one
Don't have to tell me twice don't have to tell me twice. This is my favorite kind of mission. No
Then a mine me
I love a bit of destruction
Sometimes the attachments actually change how spread works as well, so maybe doesn't spread
It usually does
I
Know now now I don't I'm going to pretend that the spread is different, so I'm gonna have to use ABS now
We're doing it we're doing it
I'm helping I'm helping I got you
I got you. I got you. I got you. I'm coming
I'm
I'm gonna help I promise when we do the galeel we haven't done the galeel. Hold on
Joe, let's do the galeel. Okay. We show. Oh, no, that's friendly
Instantly my crosshair goes on to the the allies
That's why I am a combat medic and nothing more. I have no more no more of an asset
Oh
Come down the catwalk naughty naughty boy, you're a naughty boy
Brutally mutilating people naughty boy
Nutty boy. Oh, you so naughty. Oh, yeah, naughty boy. Oh, you get spanking
I
Wonder if it will be verbal deck. Hi weaver. Where are you? You're Hudson your sergeant edwards
station it's beneath us
Not certainly broadcast
Come on, this is alpha wood. We have confirmed the result is the broadcast source
Combat paper for moral support. I'm here. Not a boy. Not a boy. Not a boy. Oh
That goes so and rather so much not a not a kill five years ago. You can't hear the difference
Yeah, not a boy
We're gonna finish this you are both nutty and
Overdivers, whoa, this is amazing. We built this
I feel like we need to decompress a bit, you know before we why what's going on
How's that was strange, I don't think I was actually supposed to like fall there or something I
It's not really letting me steer him like I can't go up or down. I'm just pressing W right now
So I think I think I'm being Disney raid parked
And I'm secretly on a track
The compression is more important for ascending
The like mushrooms way, yeah, I've got mushrooms for my soup
Okay, this is dangerous, I see why this game became so popular just for how much oh
I assume we're a lot of fire, right surely. I
Don't know if I was supposed to be a bit quiet like if we had suppressors or what but
I'm going in guns ablaze and
I'm mason
I'm best
How's the giggles stick doing today, I still broken, but thank you for asking thanks
For the super chat as well. How do I get in here? I go down. Yeah, I must go down. Excuse me. Hi
My name is Victor resolve
And I will he my means something just got me there. I don't know why I'm under a timer and before there's a secret timer
I
Was gonna say I feel like oh
There's another one okay hip-fire on Galeel
Oh
Oh, we don't have her get why would you not keep the
Why would you not keep the diving gear on you? Why is it not on our person, bro? I'm sorry. I'd be putting the mask on right now
Can the giggles take me mended yeah, I
Just I need to not be stressed and then I can be
I can be the truth my ultimate form a
Yeah, now the stress is getting left like I'm about to fit a tie-off loose ends on projects as well
From me we have
And I think next month
We'll be much more organized and we'll be able to see what the patreon audios are for the girls had the few
Developmental issues otherwise
It is it is not possible. No, it is not possible to do something for the first time
They is oh sorry, I didn't realize I was a an armored one. I was like, hmm. Why is this guy not like gone on the ground yet?
I
Okay, it seems like they have weakened the hedge
Fight me so I'm gonna just leave them
And this is
Get right
You're coming with me time for a swim, buddy
I
Gratitude check for Dragovich mama's gonna make sure you drink plenty of shift or mailing a
Million the crap of them I
Did thank you the Baylor
Hydration check for Dragovich. Oh real actually. He's just a little bit thirsty, okay?
No, I can't move. It's like making me walk really slow
Can we put our disc goodbye diving gear on again?
I don't know why we would enter an underwater ship that we knew we were gonna damage and throw nades about and didn't keep the diving
Okay. Yeah, see this this is what I wanted
Is
Well, that looks like Resulka
Wait, they have to hold their breath ascending
I'm not gonna lie. I wouldn't have made it after like 10 seconds. I would have been like
Hello
Can you be a one-eyed
USA USA USA
God bless America
Eagle screech
No, you know
Oh
No, I think I remember what happens after the credit I
Appreciate their way to do that
Oh
So they implied me send it
That is a rather wild
Very wild
They like dogs yeah, they made to him like edit them in a fit that's some dedications
Hey
Always left was our original program
Call of duty black ops
Thank you director Dave and Jason and Dan and Pat and Caesar and Charles and John and Daniel
And Sam and meals miles and Shane and Adam and John and guys and Ronnie and Andre and I can't say all these
Okay, the reason I'm gonna skip the credits which is really rude to the dev team is because they're gonna throw me into a zombie game and it freaks me
And it makes me scared so
Oh, do you want me to say in the credits? I mean without technical director of characters
Yavier and where would we be? I mean the character and
Artists Dennis more like Dennis was menacingly creating that fantastic character or
Yeah, I read tomorrow
Yeah, the game throws you into zombies and zombies freak me out. I cannot play it on my own
I get so scared on my own
I can't handle it. It just freaks me out when they're all coming at me. I
Mean the animators
Fill it just ten out of ten the way you captured
The animations of the things gorgeous lead script engineer
Dan, I'm jealous. I want your position. No not engineer lead script person scriptures
That was quite a combination not Walter white Walter Williams
Sure, you get that all the time buddy, but don't worry. You're doing great. Keep it up. I want to see more work from you
Mm-hmm
Additional design support Matt. I want to see more work from you. I want to see what you got into
I want to see what your how many fingers in the pie that you had. I want to see more work
Mm-hmm audio director Brian fantastic
absolute fantastic and
Conversions what's a conversion?
Conversion maybe is the name of the studio our interns. I know you did joke in and linear
I know you didn't get paid shit. Thank you for your contributions. However, I know you got paid fucking pennies or nothing at all
That's me there ink
Thank you
For this super chat
Floor test leads max, where would we be without you testing the floors? I have no idea
I'll clean them, but you're more you you take over testing them. Okay
Production testers at any point Kevin Tucker
Tucker hardly even know
What's that additional contributions Steve Goldberg more like Steve gold because wherever you touch turns to gold
Might as well call you midas
The hit binding of Isaac video game. I am
a
Additional cast an alphabetical order. Who's Mason?
Who's Mason's voiced by
Who's my son wait did I miss Mason? I
Don't know how I did that. I miss Mason apparently
You missed it dumb ass
They already showed him my bad. I don't know who the boys
Boys over recordings Keith just hit me up any time. I got a voice recording for you
Alex Mason is Sam Worthington
Didn't he not have a combat movie like in real life
All right, I'm making stuff up. I'll make stuff up. Don't think I won't make stuff up off the top of my head
I'll just make stuff up if I want all willy-nilly
Musicians you made the coolest like little background doonoo and that that was it city of Kowloon
That background music and that one. I'm I'm I'm popping that bad boy up, okay?
That was good additional original music composition Kevin ten out of time
gorgeous, stunning
Fantastic special thanks and to you the player. I don't know if they do that, but it would be cute if they did it
Additional writing Howard thanks Howard for your writing military and historical consultants
Don't think we weren't thinking about you
We like the historical accuracy of the flashbacks, especially Victor Reznov's flashbacks
Using time period gun relevant things. We love it here. We appreciate that attention to detail keep that up game studios
I understand you get paid in pennies
So we are thankful when you go above and beyond
We do not expect that and yet you still go for it
Even though the masses have yet to learn and acknowledge that it is not your studios that are the problem
It is the big guys breathing down your neck
We thank you for your sacrifice in both your health and your
Your personal life to make others happy and one day just know that the masses will understand that you are not the problem game
Studio it never was you it was always
the big
The publishers and
Slowly the masses will come to learn and hate
the correct
They were brave to show the real assassination or two I
Was like rather out there you live a touchy subject
No, but I mean I guess a couple of years have passed by that point
Certain affinity more like certain quality. Thank you for your contributions to black ops one activision
Again, don't hate the team
Hate the publishers
So head of production Steve you did fantastic SVP Dave. Thank you. Yeah global brand management more like global gold
You can
What is this random music from the game
What
That's Eminem
They got an Eminem song
DMCA I don't I think we'll be okay that I don't have to take down the board
I think it'll just be like I can't monetize it or anything. We're just fighting
He said this word he said
It was cool in 2010, I didn't know he was that I remember like
Did the zombie one
Did you want to punch lines
Shake it like a donkey will park
We're gonna crash gets to monetize. Yeah, basically. I think this one's for the game
Yeah, like custom he made a song for cod ghost as well. Did activision cough up the goods? I
Know that call the duty's been advertising on like drink brands in the UK
Which they don't normally do but this was years ago now
I was just very surprised seeing it like they did they did it with Doritos and they did it with this
energy drink to advertise cod
I division has pockets
Marketing communications. Thank you Susan. See it's all chicks. That's when the chicks come in
All the chicks come in when it comes to like advertise and to know that but like that's a dead site of things
It's like nothing
traffic coordinate or
Sheila Sheila
Can you believe they're trying to cancel Eminem
Eminem getting it trying to cancel me bruh Genzini bruh
I
Yeah, he made survival of the fitters for college
How am I being so daft that I can't remember any of this?
I'm sure I probably knew it and I'm just like completely like bended it. I'm like not really relevant
I'm gonna say I like ghost a lot when we play campaign
I like alien modding ghost is the best go media
I think she must yeah alien
I'm Genzi and even I love it. I don't wanna him cancel whether one
No, do you know no it's a meme no one's trying to cancel anyone Eminem no one gives a shit
The joke was like Eminem comes out and it's like they're trying to cancel me
They're trying to Genzini bruh and everyone's like what are you on about no one's talking about you
Because he's always been like
But you don't have to like like I hate to be that person's like but if you look past the lyrics like he is actually
Ghost was a decent game multiplayer. I didn't enjoy ghost multiplayer. No, I remember the credit
I
Was about to say I was like why the music just go down and it goes why'd you turn me down turn me up?
They got me they got me. I got pranked. I was like oh a bit to have like a voice over
I thought technical requirements got I did not realize how much it takes to make one freaking game. This is crazy
Considering like they had assets from
Well, I think they had assets from world at war like
Guards they ring the guards ring the guards. They're making a mockery up. Yeah ring the guards
Black Ops is cool if you just scream
Please no more copyright music you're really limiting my chances black ops if this actually remain enough
I'm gonna cry if this doesn't remain up. I will literally have to like manually yank my own board and then like
Download it and cut out all the DMCA sections because I am not having this break my freaking stream streak
I will go off stream and if it says like
Copyright blocked and I can't do anything about it. You bet your ass. I'm gonna boot up a yaps stream for like an hour
I'm not having my stream streak broken due to it. He's she copyright because
because the developers Activision like
Publish the rights to use the song in the game any gamer that plays the game in streams that should be protected
But they're not I don't know why this isn't a thing. Okay
five-minute yaps stream
I will I'll go off stream. I'll make a cup of tea and I'll do a yeah, don't think I won't
Don't think I won't
Is there any just the other girls online right now that I can redirect into?
I'm gonna let it run until it tells me about cold zombies. I'm gonna cry. No
Okay
I miss that
Now we invited you here today good faith in good faith
the sort this thing out and why is he here
He lost as I always say to give your enemies, but remember their names
And he's on a membership
Just a storm dick
I like it zombies that's it Phil stop zombies no explanation zombies
I
Gentlemen lock it down
Why did they make president Nixon's little monkey like
Okay, but seriously though Rahi look like
No
No, I ain't doing this. I would eat energy. We need power
We need power more power
Hanoi, Moscow, New York, Hong Kong the Pentagon. We're at Defconn one
Right no, we're done. I was gonna muck about until they started but I'm like now you're done. We're not doing that
I'm too scared. I'm too scared. I'm too scared. I can't do it. I can't do it. I can't do it
I'm scared deep and oh
No, you don't know what you talk about it's not a stick up anymore. It's just me
Right, it's that young study on you just stay over there. You just leave yourself. It's not a stick up. I promise. I'm behaving
I'm behaving fake arms. No
No, that's not him. Well, I said some beat you first work like that
a
Did you end up feeding the birds on the way back from the shop with a the soup chicken?
No, they never came to me. Although I met a nice lady on a walk
Like on the walk back and she was just feeding the magpies in general, but not my magpies
I don't know those aren't my magpies and I kid you not there is nine magpies around her and I was like
Oh, fuck. Yeah, I'm like having a flash into like my retirement even though I get to do it now
So that doesn't really make sense at all truly
Um
One round
No, I don't give me money to be scared. That's different
I
Can I show you guys can I leak something I'm just gonna I'm just gonna tell her
Uh, I'm just gonna leak it. I'm just gonna I've literally put I'm gonna show it on stream. I hope that's okay
Oh, please don't get mad at me. I love you
Love you, please don't get mad at me for leaking everything because I can't hold back anything from the replay
And that's okay. Sometimes that's okay
Sometimes it's okay
Are you ready? What happens tomorrow?
Oh
It's tainate. No go back
Oh, shit she beats the wrong color. Fuck
Okay, this was before
This was before
Sheepster's got our tan. Okay. This is before but we all go humanized. Look, we're all humans
We're gonna be your maids
But who are we collabing with? Well, if ain't other none other
Then baby pink ASMR. Hey, I will tweet about it. So don't worry. You're not gonna miss it
Hey, but look, we're all humanized. We'll have human eyes as well
Um, I see doesn't have her bare ears and she got hair like tied back and
Mercy still has her eye patch though, because you know, she still wants to do the yandere thing
but like emi's little um
We pumpkin things are gone because she's all hicks out the wazoo as her ears are gone
Shebe's bun bun ears are gone. I'm human too. Look. I ain't got my teeth like she
Now now my teeth you
Hey, I see without ears. It's weird, but neat
It's very cute. I think it's very cute
But yeah, like like emi's eyeballs don't have crosses or anything. No one has like
Specialized eyes. We all got human eyes for the maid camp campaign campaign
for the Mead collab
Yeah, so that's from baby pink baby pinks channel tomorrow
Um, and then there's one more big old collab like that
But that comes out later. Not yet. I've got a few things I need to do for it
This video was made for you
Oh, wait, hold on. Let me put it back on the screen
You could see this video was made for you
I'll fuck you
But just that's coming out tomorrow exciting exciting. Yeah, she's here. See my background work is coming today. Yeah
clap clap clap
Um
Hi, stranny. I like the nickname cuddle pop. I also like pop
It's a lot of this
Love you. Love you terry fun
You like that. Don't lie. You like that. Okay. Did jaffer arrow do the art? Yeah, that was a jaffer arrow art
Where's that bunk? Yes, this is jaffer arrow
uh
This was quite a whale in the making. I'm gonna be honest. This was done in june
I'm not even kidding. This was in june and it took me two months to get a three months really if you want to
Be honest. This took me three months. And then the pictures one is going to take me three months. Oh, she can forgive me
love you
Um
Hey, mommy. What happens if you press the resume campaign? Oh husky. Thank you for the
Oh
Oh, wait, I never made myself smaller. Hold on
Uh
Hi, sorry
Okay
Okay, thank you for the 50
Husky, I will play around. I'm surely I'm not incompetent enough that I'm gonna die, right?
Oh, I thought my game died
resume carnage
Right, okay. I'm gonna turn my head sit down because this I can't handle this
Okay
Okay, oh god, I can hear them
I can hear them
I can hear them stop it. Oh my god, stop it
I hate oh
Oh my game just froze there
Oh
Oh my god, stop stop stop stop stop stop stop stop
Pointing at empty
And I say
I don't know. Can I make it to round stop it go away. Let me alone. I did it
That's what you paid 50 bucks for
Mommy don't just do my I don't want to play
what the fuck is this quick revive five you give you value for why why am I
always want to give value for money
I'm gonna get overwhelmed so quickly what am I supposed to do cost 750 stop it go
home marble as marble as okay I can do it it's when they start getting leveled up
that's when it's like game over because I'm like what am I supposed to do genuine
like I can't there's no stop putting me up around what is this what is this how
do I progress what are you speed cut no that's reload what are you a thousand
bucks for debris don't you think it's a big source in it but I wanted oh my god
they take two shots now oh you've got to be joking me sorry I'm sweat I've
actually broken out in a sweat I'm not even kidding as much oh my god they
could run no they upgraded their speed oh I can't oh my god I burst out in a
swear I burst out in a sweat I don't know where to go I hear them everywhere I'm
only on round three why is there so many I don't know if I even have no they
don't die you said use the knife back in the game kids oh my gosh they jump I
didn't remember this being so hard I don't even know if I can make enough for
the debris oh my god no don't no I need I need money to go to the next floor I'm
literally as well level equal how many I think another mount weapon no I want to
try and get to the next location just so I can say I played it and then then the
tipper got his money's worth because I feel really bad that I'm like so scared
I don't want to progress go away go home okay we can progress give me the fuck
out of here ding ding ding no it cost it cost money man I hate capitalism no
no no no no go home stop I'm scared no no do not frickin show me them running at
me as I go in the elevator what's this you must turn on the power okay I can do
that surely oh god I can hear them no it's a time is this power you must turn
on the power I can hear them already what happened in the Solomon Isles I'm
already dead I put myself in the Pentagon of death I literally can't get out
yes this is exactly what I meant okay let's just say I can't play zombie you I
can play it with you that's different I then I get courage when I play with you
I cannot play it on my own frickin round four is embarrassing though that was
awful I literally I could sense the Pentagon of death because they were
coming from both sides no don't put me in another leave me alone don't put me
in another no what quit yes I want to quit jeez don't put me in another don't
be so selfish who sits and plays the same game over and over another no no
another right I want to break out for the Zork achievement though like his his
arms are supposed to try and break out no I don't want to quit wait his arm no
stop why is it on them the keyboard to to make them break out so we can please
or I'm not on I'm on mouse and keyboard
is it spacebar or space bar there you go there you go right you ready so you
get an achievement for coming out and then you come to the PC and type in ZORK
first F so you type in ZORK and you get another achievement so ready
west of house you are standing in an open field west of a white house with a
boarded front door there is a small mailbox search mailbox you find nothing
unusual open boarded door imagine if strong it plays with veteran reeflings
who know how to get to the you'd be picking me up off the ground every two
seconds I hope you're aware of that thank you group by feeling you'd literally
be picking me up online the door cannot be opened search for crowbar I don't know
the word crowbar shisell search what do you want search door hmm type in three
arc on walk I don't know that I don't know the word three arc I didn't like it
I don't know how to play ZORK I don't know how these work no not here where like
in general three arc space on look and mean them you can unlock zombie arcade
when at the computer I'm at the other computer or the main menu oh like if I
sit in the chair again and then take it then taping three arc unlock well I
didn't like that I am dumb it's in the PC back out of the chair enter it in the
PC you were just that get out of Zork in the computer though oh exit Zork got it
exit Zork where's where are you my god they have soundproofing to stop me from
screaming solo okay exit game oh wait no exit game close game and game what I
can't get out am I being dumb let me keep exit this orc game yeah
press F to use the computer press exit exit exit don't know the word exit three
arc unlock three arc unlock no space are we in Zork right now don't know the word
are we aren't sir it go behind house move behind how the fuck did you play
games in the past like this move behind house door there was no verb in that
exit Zork I'm not being trolled move the house go behind white house
type in cardinal direction I don't know the word cardinal enter a window search
for window these games are you can't see any window what quit I got zero point you
yes okay and then three arc unlock cheeks enabled now what I go back in the
chair
obviously you said I'm not the zombie mode
nope wait where was that thing now set in place on the arcade no I'll get
folks I won't let me in it isn't zombie snow oh no sorry not online solo oh it
is step back through time with this retro arcade zombie adventure to do battle
with the forces of the cosmic silver back
me dead ops arcade insert coin did I do it oh this is kind of less scary I hear
them they have like unlimited ammo oh this isn't a scary cuz like I know I'm a
weak gamer choose your path choose your challenger I would like to go across the
bridge please remember look top left what happens I have a nuclear bomb minigun
for maximum push the whirlwind strap yeah you like choose your chicken oh the
chicken came back to see oh this is my kind of game the chicken eyes are
familiar and helps me shoot I'm here for it so did if they touch me dad I is it
like old-school old-school whereas the game doesn't forgive you for not like
spraying I got raygun round two complete where'd we like to go in the water and
thank you I don't think up the bridge come on mr. chicken let's go claim some
rocks
they'll lose mr. chicken what was that bonus room discovered don't mind if I do
hello hello how do I use my ultimates it says I have two nuclear bombs you have
lives okay let's go back across the bridge like everything chicken is all
in temporary I can't believe it I would have won this game if it wasn't for the
fact that the chicken didn't stay I'm mad oh I'm really sway holy crap I just
moved my legs like I know I'm scared but damn I was limited I'm I got that
inside of my thighs are really sway oh there I got like bones and things get
away from me you know we flinch did they hurt them I don't know oh this one isn't
scary they're a bit terrifying but I mean if I die it's not baby oh well we see
how long we can go and then we'll redirect into zero F2 nuke okay let's
go treasure room again question mark if it's a skull is always a treasure room
no it is not it is a misconception do not be
misconception lies
teddy bear aura sends them away curious well how long did it okay I'm starting
to understand why I took them so long to make this game and so many people got
credit this is insane can you do multiplayer on this game mode this is a
cool game mode I like it
oh no wait I got touched me gems or something I don't know what happened
sorry I was too busy looking at the shots going absolutely mental me million
dollar step on the teleporter to enter a new arena I saw that you're trying to
hate my gemstones from me give me them back they snuck up from we're getting
teleported we are now in Casablanca I love Mexico I like the 8-bit music from
unfortunately I don't think I'm gonna be women okay I love this shotgun that's
ridiculous and the game knows it that is hilarious no give me more of that that's
what I want Oregon okay I'm not gonna reserve ammo I'm missing though my aim
but it's all round complete though whoa are you enemy
what do you do go away you're scaring me I don't know what you are
speed gun we control now the cosmic gorilla bonus room they jump in me I saw
that video game don't think I didn't see that wait why are they giving me so
much bonus runs must really be that valuable bonus room sorry I don't want
let's take a look at an excellent enemy monkey monkey monkey I like that I like
being silly and like do not windmell he did he did he not enough oh it's the
flaming buffer hello later
we can see do it yeah I don't understand yeah
zip hunts I have fantastic news Hans oh my god I have fantastic news we are
now in a tank and I do I just need to be careful the tank running out with when I
don't expect it this is so cute you stop that you naughty boy choose your path I
think we take left again oh but I'll grab these this is so cute I'm not scared
when the zombies are like this cuz I think cuz I like get so streamlined in
a game that it's like oh my god they're actually coming which makes me scared
what is that take my my balls get ball of fat oh no my I've only got three balls now
oh oh dear oh I've cornered myself now that's dangerous I guess the best method would be to
go in circles as best you can and then we can min max me why yes of course that's how zombies work
what's this one hold on let me put it down oh yes please thank you I like the familiar ones
because it helps lay down cover fire and it makes everything cheaper why do I keep getting spanked
by enemies something keeps teleporting on top of me and blackouts for you can switch using top
down mode on first print nope absolutely not I'll stick to top down this is safe this is not scary
whereas like the actual first person is like scary I think they're probably gonna be getting a bit
difficult I don't know like cuz I only made it to round four in the other game mode so I'm not
sure how successful I'm gonna be in this one no no no I want the thing oh um me gems me gems
will someone please think about me lucky charms they're jumping me I keep corner I'm yeah I keep
getting myself cornered oh I'm dead no I'm not dead I have two more lives okay that's fine the game's
getting hot I was joking about it getting hard over come on I'm gonna jump twice for these a bomb
oh no it's gone ah wait is f not a bomb is it grenade oh it's grenade step on the teleporter
no I need to get all the items first you almost jinxed me I don't know if I can grab them all
no not quite challenge range prison break what does that mean give me that chicken he's gonna
help me break out here right so f is when it's all too much wait those are surrogates oh no I'm
missing ops hold on those are surrogates I can tell I said I'm not gonna make it I can't
I'm gonna get a decent score I think
about this isn't easy
fetch me I don't know what the lightning strike is unfortunately
there appears to be a lightning strike I don't know how to activate it oh no
oh sorry I was trying to activate it and I looked away I don't why is it hgy trwq he
said shift I don't know what the lightning strike symbol is
shift is dash oh to get out of a here he said you should all right let's go right
I assume it's just angle sweeps the armory discovered yeah give me that chicken that's what I want
give me that fucking chicken the armory oh my god my chicken army grows every day
the humans are no match the zombies are no match for me my chicken
clock clock motherfucker where are they come on chickens you ready RPGs at the ready chickens
attack you come to the wrong flock to be around these parts that's right motherfucker
no if I could just permanently have the chickens with me I'd win this game easy
oh monkey monkey monkey oh my yings are gone like I put a lot of time and effort into those yikens okay
oh we're getting some funky music I then need to be bench so let the funky music do the
ooh I think so the chicken meadow is real
untrue I've created the new meadow because nobody wants to see shit and no more they want
poultry
whoa it's getting heady I'm sure we're getting out of this one
getting difficult it's getting difficult difficult lemon difficult
okay but we've got a chicken so it's easy easy easy peasy lemon squeezy
if you ever wanted to know what the opposite of easy peasy lemon squeezy is it's difficult
difficult lemon difficult that's how you do it I don't know what the the coil things are
I needed a bomb I'm like can I let you keep myself
don't think I won't be daft enough to come on chicken fuck them up for me
show them how you really feel chicken about being turned into poultry all the time yeah
oh we got a century
oh that's entry wow he almost got me oh no no this the zombies didn't kill me
wait scrawny am I dead yeah
why did you sound so disappointed in me I can't believe the oh yeah oh yeah I did it
me back
what the my treasure
bye bye
the chaos emerald game over you made it to round 11 yep
that was funny I didn't know you even know that was in there
I want to try and play zork no don't put me back in you're gonna scare me quit I want to quit
I don't know how to play zork though do you guys know how to play zork you can win oh there's
like a finish what let me read all pen pals you're about to get read it into a zero
well as there is weight room she's not off just yet hi amy I had your dinner membership stream
I hope you had fun with your pen pals hi pen pals we just play we just finished the college
black ops one campaign we just wait what we're done I'm gonna try and figure out how zork works
because this stupid computer like it is an old game in it okay and it's like these old games
where you have the text and type there's nothing on screen you're just fighting with literally
you're fighting with characters on a screen to try and get the game to work and that's what I'm
trying to do it it's college zombie game it has zombie mode in it but it is a first person shooter
and we just finished arcade around on zombies but this stuff is like there's a small mailbox
we are standing in an open field and where field west of a white house so I need to go
feel I need to go west this is the forest with trees in all directions to the east
there appears to be sunlight right go east uh forest path this is the path winding through
a dimly lit forest a path heads north south here one particularly large tree with some
low branches stands on climb tree up a tree you are about 10 feet above the ground nestled among
some large branches the nearest branch above you is above your reach beside you on the branches
of the small bird's nest and the bird's nest is a large egg encrusted with precious jewels
apparently scavenged by a childless songbird what is this this egg is covered with fine gold in lay
and ornamented in lapis lazuli and mother of peril unlike most eggs this one is hinged
and closed with a delicate looking class the egg appears extremely open egg carefully
I don't open egg fucks sake ungebunga open egg in the little smash you neither have the tool okay take
egg take in okay uh down tree there was a climb down tree uh east there's a dimly lit forest east
the forest ends out nearing impact okay north north the forest becomes in pen okay south
uh okay what east what i thought east was bought wow okay we've got somewhere we've got somewhere
hold on eat the egg oh okay eat egg i don't think that the jeweled and crusted egg would
agree with you the game called me ungebunga how do you canyon view you're at the top of a great
canyon on its well oh and it's on its west wall from here there is a marvelous view of a canyon and
past parts of a frigid river upstream across the canyon the walls of the white cliff ah this is
too much reading can you shorten it thanks um open egg no i don't have tools um i'm a i'm a
read marshmallows how about that because i that's too many words that's too many words for my brain
yeah oh yeah open the egg chat gpt please or for me literally that's too much reading
reading out loud is different reading out loud is different um but yeah for any pinpals that are
lurking spoilers guess what happens tomorrow spoilers uh uh uh thank you i use zuri for
becoming a member please enjoy your emotes thanks for the support and spoilers that'll
cause the spoilers now you're not allowed to see the spoilers so i'm gonna finish with them no no you're not
got a woman that's a lot of words kernel too bad i'm reading them
boom boom boom don't read this out loud
oh that's quite the conspiracy for you hi stony don't worry if you bust out in a sway i'll look
obvious true real and then i'm all caught up i'm all shook up in the door
oh we need to do karaoke but i need to do a two hour stream before the karaoke
commences are you squinting me right now you deserve head pads cute up also here's my cherry
please be gentle with it yeah now please give me that sweet sweet streamer interaction dopamine
oh yeah you're ready for it are you ready for the dopamine rush
i thank you for giving me your cherry wink wink nine thousand
are your toes curling in your seat are you dry rating are you vibrating did you get the serotonin
from calling me a pup huh did you feel cheeky taping it out in your message now you're super chat
cherries
yeah okay um is there any way i can send bib use of your tentacle you can is it possible through
how so this is magical website called cat box
lucky shy lol you ain't
okay i think oh right if everything goes to plan
if everything goes to plan my toes curl does that count yeah you put your you put yourself in
that reefland's place and your toes were curling or do they or do they just curl when i'm like
good morning good evening good afternoon he's asking the real question like he's a brave reefland
okay be nice be nice be nice okay i'm all caught up i'm marching my toes i'm going to make sure i'm
100 redirecting into a zero or i'm gonna i'm gonna fart i'm not i'm gonna fart
do you guys force farts though just out of curiosity right hold on let me type in as there
is delay azura cuz she be isn't on today she be resting she be cutting bed you can't be
why she done why she up to oh she already completed stream oh silly me uh right azura do
lee azura delay more like azura do don't a thon in a few days
please show up to her don't a thon i beg instead of please clap please just show up and lurk that's
all i'm asking i don't ask for much you don't even have to give money just please just sit and watch
your stream she has so much plans and i would i would hate for her to know that she would feel
like it wouldn't be you know you know what i'm you know what i'm trying to say you know when you
go above and beyond for a stream uh and especially all the plans behind the scenes with the stream
in mind um that's when i'm like uh yeah your marshmallow will fill it i thought they didn't
get filled alert how can i find your cat box to send it to no you send it in marshmallow
but the link is a cat box link thank you for this dream moment i'm going to enjoy it i like playing
i it's considered this is actually a childhood game because i was a child when i played it
well roughly roughly you know like i'll be it and no quite no quite but you know what i mean
this is technically a childhood game that was a fun because i got to play again what is the
agendation for the rest of the week though i have completely forgotten i need to prepare for the
hypnosis stream because i need to write the script for it well i've got peggle oh i have a
brainless stream tomorrow a i take the wheel i don't have to think and it's gonna be glorious
glorious and then i have a members balochro stream where i'm going to spam some cards down
she's gonna peggle i'm gonna peggle all the room you're gonna peggle you so hard
i really enjoy the tame and feel her i'm glad it's lots of fun with the girls especially when
we get to do stuff together mommy's a master peggar and yee mommy never played league game peggle
with a meta pegging stratton lord no is there actually um yes tomorrow's agendation is peggle
ai i don't know how long it's actually going to take me to finish the quote unquote peggle one
campaign mode i think we literally got halfway through it so i assume we're gonna finish it
and then i've got a members balochro stream and then the two days after that i've got like two days
in a row i'm going to be starting two hours earlier than usual this is not permanent this is
temporary i'm going straight back to my usual time slot um so europeans rejoice that you might not
be exhausted by the end of a longer stream or particularly longer day um we are doing golf
at colab and then i'll redirect into a zero then i am going to boot up a very quick maybe one hour
stream nothing major nothing thingy i do i would prefer if you had a zero on uh on in the background
or had your attention you know chan engage me a little yes um and then i will be doodling my gen
mates and then i will redirect into a zero again at the end of that and then i need to prepare for
my hypness hyp no ses a s n r and then i need to decide on what my content's gonna be next week
because i said i was going to do overwatch and then i checked my list and then i couldn't sit
overwatch anywhere but i think i can sit overwatch somewhere i just need to shuffle things up around
a little bit i'm a dumb you know dumb why is that a wink or your model crash no i'm drawing my gen
mates on azur's during azur's donathan yep that's right hypnosis stream hips noses stream
i just swirl my hips around in a circle oh you're so hypnotized it's one 30 moment i have working
go to go to bed in six hours go to bed right now spank spank spank go big no go big no no i'm
angry go big go big go to sleep go big spank what is your favorite multiplayer black ops one
class attachment equipment parts oh right you're not gonna like this i prefer playing the support
class and what i mean by that is uav counter uav and sr 71 for the killstreaks uh famis so i had two
loadouts if i wanted to be big bang boom and my teammates were doing fine i would be joe mag famis
with joe wield python and then for my pecs uh perks i would have hacker um i would have oh no i've
forgotten the other slots but if my teammates were doing shit i went i went full ghost i did like ghost
hacker so i could see equipment and like a suppressor um and i did the the uav shoot down thing
because if my teammates were doing shit the enemy team would always have fucking uav all the time so
i had to i had to be the one to shoot it down because everyone was selfish or they'd start
shooting at the things with their guns and i'm like bro just swap a class you've got five class
slots wow uh over what stream same's gonna happen when i'm at the country i don't know if it's a
probably gonna save your sanity unironically okay how hot did you get me to talk about
i really want to see how journal plays i'll be interested i mean at least like we'll find games
quickly when we play together because um yes i think uh the servers have been revived a little
bit since journal got released they were saying their servers are dead i don't know how true that
is obviously i'm not played overwatching like yon's um maybe didn't know i used to be a bit of an
evil over overwatch overwatch fiend um and i used to like i used to game okay i have a stupid
amount of hours on it and then they ruined it and i was just stopped playing just took my hands off
i was like no i'm not clutching this again over at servers are needed i've been playing for years
i'll know about overwatches reaper go burr and bashing go burr yeah bashing go burr reaper go
i would rock the same weapon in killstreak but i would get lightweight
i never bothered about marathan fast hands like i'd rather not get caught
shooting and then have to reload like that really annoyed me um
oh just i'll see if i can squeeze overwatch stream thanks
thank you and welcome um hi strong hi reaplan oh for the past few days all i've been able to
think about is your pheromone mags and you just sit on my face let me take no i look i'm not gonna
say anything but the clam is just because i was sweating playing that zombie section that can
literally seal it and i'm like rub this is why when i say my chair you could like literally take
a dna sample and duplicate me from my chair alone because it's got every every little
bit of thing on it i'm i'm bucket right now i wear i wear my hoodie thing like the in the
comfy hoodie thing but i don't wear anything on the bottom now because it's completely redundant
i don't need anything last time i played overwatch mccree was still mccree than i am mccree apparently
if you call mccree you're like xyz elemental penis like bro please relax please relax uh
when i get home i want clam for dinner with a nice white wine poured down your chest my chest
for dessert i want your cake honey glaze with whipped cream and a cherry garnish popped into
your oh no a cherry a cherry a finish off the cake what how do you take the cherry out with your teeth
with your tongue how would you even fish that out that thing's locked up it's like a clamp it's
like a vase how are you gonna take the cherry out you're gonna you're gonna pull the fucking stem
and the cherry stays inside who's gonna fix this problem because it wasn't me that started it you
should have thought ahead of that shouldn't you riefling now have a cherry stuck in my fucking
arse can you imagine i'm like whipped cream on my butt and everything i'm really having a 60 time
and i'm like oh well what do we do now you're gonna have to fuck it over me what the fuck
essentially what are you supposed to do that's why there's no food play in the bedroom okay that's
how you get ants your wishes mike i gotta do what i gotta do god i want to be that chair so much
right now
i'll make that because that is listen oh well the cherry could get trained to use play in the future
but i can't afford it you want ants that's how you're gonna get ants
mm-hmm that's exactly exciting this rubble for the troll right i'm definitely redirected into
zero so if it has a heart attack that's literally not on me i couldn't either because it deserves an
absolute spanking azura duly i'm gonna grab the stream link as well um right my reeflings
agendination my offline agent i'm just gonna spam this here so you can put it in the corner
because you're gonna you're gonna help you're gonna support my daughter even though she is
literally mommy go support my daughter um pop that in the background uh have a little humble
maybe azura might human humanify herself without a that toggle again everyone is really scared of
her human toggle hey i watched some of her birthday and it was so cute she's going through the artwork
some stuff there's a very a kind gifted artwork about her keycaps well which i really like um
i love mama you need i cannot wait to order my moot batch i can't wait use ink as listed now hold on
a minute get rated nerd yeah exactly beat them up um but no thank you for the stream as for the
agendination when i go offline um possibility of an ASMR upload pretty high possibility of the third
patreon audio yes yes that will be up um and a for any background stuff that i can leak
and not yeah unfortunately i need to stop leaking stuff about the girls me me and shebe were talking
or like spamming each other in the dms and i was like oh my god i can't wait until this thing leaks
and and i was like i've already leaked it to the reeflings i can't remember hold on let me let me
check the answer i've already i forgot what we were meme we're memeing about hold on let me just
let me just hotkey reeflings because like reef i'm like reefling reefling i have inner dms i've
already mentioned gel even times um i was just talking to i was like oh funny reeflings mentioned
today who'd be a good mentor and i was like oh speaking to you about it because she's talking
about more about the the development side she wanted to see more of the development side i'm
like sure i'll tell you where you want to know um but yeah i've already leaked to the reeflings
oh that was it uh my donor thought and i was like i've already leaked my donor song goes like ages
ago i kind of help i just leak all over your face but you like it this way yeah thank you for the
nostalgia i'm glad you enjoyed it that's fine don't forget to check the stream board for dmc oh i
all right i will redirect into us or i'll i'll have a bow i'll tweet i'll tweet uh i'm i don't
know i don't even have any memes to tweet i'm not really that creative i'm gonna cut oh no i don't
have a dm on twitter i'm scared i'm being cancelled i'm being cancelled i can't believe it i'm
cancelled oh shit oh hey it's a v-tripper the one i'm f**king
oh what the heck damn with friends like these holy s**t that's okay what the f**k
damn someone say it whoa i can't believe it what the f**k
damn what goes around comes around holy f**k okay that was really nice i didn't expect that uh
so i was helping some v-tubers in the background not relate to veal or just in general because
they're in a shitty situation and one of their friends have gone out their way to dm me on twitter
and say thanks for helping them and i didn't expect that and that was really nice holy f**k that
that feels nice to get recognition my heart feels very full right now
i as the way hold on i'm a puller i'm a puller up don't think i won't
don't think i'm pulling up the quote right now i'm pulling it up i don't care i don't
care how many times i need to say this quote i don't care how many times i will say this quote
i'm gonna say it some believe it is only great power that can hold evil and check
but that is not what i have found it is the small everyday deeds of ordinary folk
that keep the darkness at bay small acts of kindness and love
that is the small everyday deeds of ordinary folk that keep the darkness at bay
love it love it i did not expect that my heart feels very full right now that was very kind of
i will message that lovely girl back and thank her for her kind words and her
straightforwardness because that was so cute moddy hair splined mods mods get them wait mods can't
time each other out ah well okay right i am going to go and check what the status of this f**king
stream is because i'm about to get hit with dmca the moment i hit in blue mod 0 3 1 16 wait
1 6 yeah a little love goes a long way it does i didn't expect that i thought the message was
going to be like hey you want to do an ace mark lab i'm like f**k yeah i want to do an ace mark lab
and then it's like oh thank wait i don't i'm not gonna i'm not gonna say too much
uh i'm gonna say uh i wanted to send you a deep and heartfelt thank you message for helping
um x y elemental p and uh yeah i didn't expect that that was very kind so i'm gonna i'm gonna
reply uh yes right i'm gonna end stream you'll be redirected into azura's success successfully
and if not i'll go myself as i said ace mark video upload very likely uh newest patreon role
play will also be going up by the time i see you tomorrow for our pegging peg a little adventures
went going um the numbers mason what do they mean this is such a fun time thank you i'm glad
you enjoyed this stream i had so much fun as i said i do love being a cheeky cheeky bam and just
weak playing games i've played before in another you know okay but thank you so so much reeflands
please remember to hydrate to stretch to go to the toilet and make sure you get food i have been so
distracted by this game i have had one bottle of water and a half cup of tea so i'm gonna go behave
and look after myself okay um please please please make sure you stretch because we've been gaming
for quite a while i didn't expect to get so distracted but i was locked in i was having a
fantastic time with you so thank you for letting me enjoy myself and and be myself and my goofy
self i know with the nova 16 it took me like eight times to grab the freaking thunder waffle
stomper my barber but i just had a fantastic time so thank you for being you and thank you for letting
me be me in order to have fun with you okay a yes i will see you tomorrow for peggling
adventures i'll i'll peg you very deep and then some ballot show mindless game bar game bar game
bot and gambas i remember smash that like button if you enjoyed this stream actually it actually
does my a smarts are always like more liked over general streams which makes sense don't get me wrong
if you like a smart please i'm not dogging on you you'll never guess how much i like a smart and
i'm the one who produces it um but yes thank you so so much i will keep you guys up to date with
anything fun and interesting that i can leak because at the moment it pay i literally was saying
ashibi i was like it pains me that i can't leak this current leaking thing as it pains me it hurts
so okay like and subscribe for my content use code strani so i'll kiss you
and remember to support zur especially on her donut on even if you're just watching
you know when the viewer count is bigger and the normal in a live stream i guess recommended more
as well so like peep more lurkers and peeps can like show up and be like oh oh his room's kind of
cool yeah yeah so don't be afraid to lurk i know i'm going to be lurking 12 hours she's
she's giving me a run for my money i thought i was the endurance streamer it's going to be a
glad you had a good time with black ops one yeah and we're going to put more well more called
later but not right away like later okay right thank you so so much i'm going to kiss you on
your forehead on your nose on your lips on your decolletage on your neck yeah
and i'll see you tomorrow for pagolin because you're begging you're begging for a pagolin aren't
you i were really really skirting the filler with that one me when the stream gets demonetized oh
the shock the horror well actually no copyright so i don't get anything from anyway okay all right
i love you i'ma stop stalling i'ma go rest and eat and hydrate and rest and like gimley and
the google shows so they don't use the sandbox i've got for them okay right i love you i'll see you
tomorrow please behave and please stretch and look after yourself and get some food and get some
more and hydrate and make sure you be able to make things you did you do and wash your hands
with soap after you think oh and before you eat it
i don't want to go i don't want to go i need to i need to do responsibilities and things i
don't want to go by
as you're in one of them okay as you're in one of our copium
okay i go how many missions are in black oaks 11
did that work did that work i think it worked i think you could tell oh there's 15
well 19 19 19 okay we did it okay bye i go i go look after myself okay only if you
look after yourself bye bye see you tomorrow okay bye
enjoy yourself
really ladies no don't start giving me money and go baby be a good girl and go
hey i'm going i'm going i'm the baby lord thank you i did say thank you for the last one i thought
that okay i go i go bye bye remember that time m&m came on at the okay i'm going i'm sorry i'm
going bye go get some tea